Die Ligatour ist wieder da, wir wollen sprechen über die Serie A, die Ligue 1, La Liga und die Premier League. Und das tun wir mit David Froché, de Paul Lévoix, mit Alex Treuker, mit Christian Bernhardt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und später kommt noch Uli Hebel dazu, was für eine Legendenrunde schon wieder los geht's.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier eine so tolle Runde habe, wenn auch mit gemischter Laune, wegen des Champions League-Verlaufs. Ich habe das Gefühl, Alex das erste Wort übergeben zu müssen. Bist du nicht zufrieden?
Ich hätte gerne auf das erste Wort verzichtet, denn ich glaube, wenn der FC Barcelona weitergekommen wäre, hättest du mir wahrscheinlich nicht das erste Wort gegeben.
Was ist denn das hier für eine fiese Unterstellung?
Ich bin eher nicht zufrieden. Das ist völlig korrekt.
Hallo, du weißt doch, warst du im Vorgespräch da, dass ich mit dir hatte? Habe ich mich nicht klar positioniert? Ich hätte nichts dagegen gehabt, wenn PSG nicht weitergekommen wäre. Ich brauche diese Konstrukte nicht so weit im Wettbewerb.
Ja, also aus spanischer Sicht, zwei sind raus, einer weiter. Also es lief ein bisschen suboptimal. Es hätte besser laufen können. Wir wollen ja die spanische Fahne hochhalten und da muss ich sagen, Atletico enttäuschend, Barca hat eine Riesenchance vergeben, enttäuschend. Real Madrid hat vielleicht sogar überperformt, weil ich glaube, so viele hatten sie nicht auf dem Zettel, dass sie City den amtierenden Champions League-Sieger rauswerfen. Aber zwei von drei raus ist unterm Strich halt doch suboptimal, würde ich sagen.
Kleine Anekdote hierzu. Also Punkt eins, natürlich habe ich von City gegen Real nicht sehen können, weil ich war gestern im Stadion und dann lief aber in der Mixed Zone, lief es dann auf dem auf dem großen Bildschirm und dann wurde kurz eingeblendet. 14 zu 0 Ecken. Dann habe ich kurz nachgeguckt, ah, 30 zu irgendwie sechs Schüsse oder so. Ich so, okay, alles klar, es läuft genau erwartbar. Und dann lief das Elfmeterschießen und dann entspannten sich alle, weil wir uns einig waren, na gut, also dann kommt jetzt keiner der Spiele raus, die schauen jetzt auch alle das Elfmeterschießen und dann, und dann erst wird wieder für uns gearbeitet und mitten während des dritten Schütten kommt Joshua Kimmich raus. Und das war wirklich interessant zu sehen, welche Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann nach vorne gehasstet sind und welche gesagt haben, ne, ich guck das jetzt hier erst fertig. Ich hab's fertig geguckt. Aber das fand ich schon lustig, dass er es nicht mal angeguckt hat. David, willst du über Champions League sprechen?
Nö. Ich hab mir im Vorfeld überlegt, welche Teams bringe ich heute mit und dachte mir irgendwie, mein Gott, PSG ist ja sowieso das, was man generell mitbekommt. Braucht man hier vielleicht gar nicht Ligatour groß besprechen. Spannender aus französischer Sicht ist ja sowieso eigentlich dann heute Europa League Conference League. Da stehen Marseille und Lidl beide so auf der Kippe. Lidl hattet ihr aber letztes Mal schon, Marseille hatte ich auch schon mal mitgebracht. Ich hab jetzt zwei andere Vereine in der Tasche.
Ja, da freu ich mich auch schon sehr drauf. Und Christian, aber eine Frage muss ich dir endlich auch noch stellen. Hey, Inter Mailand beißt sich so hart in den Arsch, wie sich noch nie jemand in den Hintern gebissen hat. Wollt grad sagen, ich konnte jetzt ja nichts aus italienischer Sicht aktiv beisteuern zu den Viertelfinalrückspielen, aber ja, genau der Eindruck, was hätte sein können für Inter. Ich bleib dabei, für Inter wäre, ich würde sagen, alles möglich gewesen diese Saison. Und so, wie sie gegen Atletico raus sind und jetzt, wie es dann auch weiter lief, bitter. Aber ja, das ist die Champions League. Und jetzt wird es halt doch das deutsch-deutsche Finale, das wir alle erwartet haben. Und ja, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich lag falsch. Ich hab gesagt, schminkt euch den fünften Champions League-Platz ab. Ich gebe es zu, ich lag falsch, aber das kann man doch nicht kommen sehen. Also, diese Verzwergung von Arsenal. Ich bin gespannt, ob da später Uli noch was dazu sagen wird. Das war schon interessant. Aber wir starten jetzt rein in die Ligatur. Und David, nachdem du jetzt schon angekündigt hast, nicht über das Offensichtliche sprechen zu wollen, was ich ja sehr schön finde. Das ist ja das, was für mich zumindest dieses Format so schön macht. Beginn doch gerne mal mit deinem ersten Thema. Was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ja, ich habe mich tatsächlich mal angeschaut, wen wir denn so hatten in den letzten Monaten an Teams. Und dabei ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich hier vor ziemlich genau einem Jahr, im Frühling 23, glaube ich, zum letzten Mal über Reims gesprochen habe. Weil da Will Stihl seit ein paar Monaten Trainer war, da war dieser Tweet über ihn erschienen, dass der Verein für ihn Strafe zahlen muss, weil er keinen Trainerschein hat und dass er angeblich Fußball, wie er Football-Manager gelernt hat… Der Football-Manager-Typ, genau, genau, genau.
Großer Fan.
Man kann da auch gerne die Aufnahmen mal reinhören, da habe ich ziemlich ausführlich auch über Mannschaft, über Historie und so geredet, habe auch fest klargestellt schon mal, dass das beides nicht ganz so richtig ist und habe geschildert, dass er eine Siegesserie hingelegt hat mit Ras damals. Die Saison ist geendet auf Platz 11 und ich finde, es wird Zeit für ein Update, weil sie sind aktuell auf Platz 8. Sie sind drei Punkte von Platz 6 entfernt, der für Europa reicht eventuell. Je nachdem, wer da so das Pokalspiel gewinnt und vier Punkte von Platz 5 entfernt, der sicher für Europa reicht. Das ist insgesamt so ein bisschen ähnlich wie in der Bundesliga. Dieser Kampf um Europa mit so einer ähnlichen Mixtur aus Clubs, die da so Licht und Schatten zeigen. Lance ist da mit drin, Nizza, Kopf von oben runter getrudelt, Marseille drängt so ein bisschen noch nach über Rennen, hatte ich letztes Mal gesprochen. Das Spannende aktuell ist, wir haben in der Liga derzeit nur einen halben Spieltag. Ein Teil der Clubs hat nur 28 Spiele, weil die Liga gesagt hat, wir haben Leute bei Europa mit dabei, da schonen wir euch doch mal, damit ihr schön euch auf Europa vorbereiten könnt. Alles für den Koeffizienten, die Liga, die kann Deutschland doch abfangen. Ich habe heute Morgen gelesen, sollte jetzt das Spiel PSG Dortmund auf den 30. gelegt werden, nicht auf den 1. Mai, wird dasselbe Problem nochmal kommen. Da ist im Vorfeld ein Spiel gegen Le Havre am 27. das wollen sie auch nochmal umlegen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie sie das im Saisonsport alles unterbekommen wollen. Aber gut.
Sie haben es auf den 1. Mai gelegt, du UEFA, deswegen.
Ah ja?
Das wird umgegangen werden. Genau, das ist jetzt in der Nacht passiert.
Dann, also Reims. Reims war kurzfristig schon mal auf Platz 7, die haben so ein bisschen Verletzungs-Sorgen. Wichtigster Stürmer ist verletzt, haben jetzt auch am Wochenende kleinen Dämpfer bekommen, haben gegen Strasbourg verloren, aber sind noch im Rennen. Und das hatte ich auch letztes Mal eben schon gesagt, dass sie ja in den 50ern waren sie einer der größten Clubs Europas, aber seitdem eben nicht mehr. Das wäre also tatsächlich ziemlicher Wahnsinn. Und – Spoiler alert – also Will Still ist immer noch da. Der ist immer noch Trainer. Still Trainer in Reims. Es gab einen kleinen Umbruch im Vergleich zum vergangenen Jahr, vor allem in der Offensive. Aber man kann sich das nochmal anhören. Von denen, die ich damals beschrieben habe, sind noch ein paar da. Der Innenverteidiger, Akbar Du, der hat eine ziemliche Entwicklung gemacht. Ein schöner, konstanter Spieler. Der hat ja nicht so gut angefangen, seine Karriere bei Reims. Er hatte direkt drei rote Karten und fünf gelbe Karten kassiert. Hat aber jetzt diese Saison nur eine einzige gelbe Karte. Ein bisschen tragischer hätte im Nationalteam der Elfenbeinküste sein können, dass er einen Titel gewonnen hat, aber er wurde nicht mitgenommen. Wer gegangen ist, und das ist relativ entscheidend für die Story, ist Matusiva. Der ist zu den Rivalen nach Rennes gegangen im Winter. Und das war ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Baustein im defensiven Mittelfeld von Rennes. Der hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass sie jetzt im Januar, Februar so ein bisschen schlechte Zeit hatten. Und das hat zwei Dinge gezeigt an Will Steele. Zum einen, er ist ambitioniert. Und das hat er sehr, sehr deutlich gemacht, dass er das überhaupt nicht in Ordnung findet, dass Ras Stammspieler verkauft. Dass er da mehr möchte, dass er da mehr erwartet, vielleicht auch zu viel erwartet von einem kleinen Verein. Und B, dass er Antworten finden kann, weil das hat er nämlich. Er hat erst versucht, konnte man sehen, Matusiva zu ersetzen, mit Cunet, mit Stambouli. Das hat aber alles nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt ist er von seinem System abgegangen, von seinem bis daher 4-3-3 und spielt jetzt häufiger mit zwei Sechser statt mit einem, mit so einem 4-4-1-1. Darunter auch mit so einem jungen Aton Gana, den kann man mal im Blick behalten. Sehr junger, vielseitiger Spieler, der war in der Vorsaison noch zweite Mannschaft, ist schon seit der U17 in RAS und war U17 Europameister, 22, in einem Team mit Mathis Tell und Saire Elmery. Auch nicht so das allerschlechteste Team, wo er dabei war. Und mit all diesen Umstellungen hat RAS es jetzt geschafft, so ein bisschen wieder die Kurve zu kriegen. Haben ein 2-2 gegen PSG erreicht, haben gegen Lyon unentschieden gespielt. Warum das gar nicht so schlecht ist, erzähle ich später noch. Haben gegen Nizla gepunktet. Also das ist durchaus beeindruckend. Es gibt auch mittlerweile diverse kleine Videos, wo sich Will Still zu Taktiken äußert. Unter anderem eins, wo er in 20 Minuten sein allererstes Spiel für RAS analysiert, sein 0-0 gegen PSG. Witzigerweise gesponsert von, nah ausgerechnet, dem Football-Manager. Also du siehst eine Handschrift bei ihm. Er lässt aggressiv spielen. Er rückt seine zentralen Mittelfeldspieler meist ziemlich weit hoch. Die laufen auch oft ins Abseits. Scheint ein guter Kommunikator zu sein. Bisschen auch ein Kuleriker. Ist schon zweimal auf die Tribüne geschickt worden. Nimmt auch keinen Blatt vorm Mund. Hat jetzt bei der Nierlage gegen Straßburg gesagt, das sei kollektiver Selbstmord gewesen. Weil sie hatten ja 1-0 geführt. Und es gab jüngst eine Athletics-Serie über 6 innovative europäische, jungen Manager. Da war auch Thiago Motta dabei. Und da war eben auch Still dabei. Da haben sie das alles noch ein bisschen erzählt, was sich auch schon ausgeführt hat über seinen Hintergrund. Da kam aber auch raus, dass er sehr deutlich sagt, naja, er würde ja gerne nach Hause kommen. Nach Hause. Und nach Hause meint in dem Fall nicht Belgien. Er ist ja in Belgien geboren, aber eben von englischen Eltern. Also er meint England. Hätte gesagt, er hätte da gar kein Problem damit. Auch mal bei einem Championship-Team zu arbeiten. Und er sei ja eigentlich auch froh, wenn er nicht alle sechs Monate das Team neu denken müsste. Insofern, der Vertrag läuft, glaube ich, noch bis 2025 offiziell. Aber er hat anscheinend eine Ausstiegsklausel von 4 Millionen. Das ist jetzt für Premier League oder selbst englische Zweitliga-Vereine nicht so teuer.
Zwei Anmerkungen dazu. Zum einen, es gibt den Fangesang Worsters on fire, your coaching staff is terrified. Das singen die an jedem Spiel, oder? So naheliegend, das muss sein. Und war denn Hugo Ektk unter Worstil fit? Ich frage für jemanden, den du auch gut kennst. Der ist ja auch gewechselt. Er war ja ausgelehnt und dann haben sie ihn festverpflichtet und dann ist er zu PSG gegangen.
Ich glaube eben auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, gut, wir sehen im Fitnesszustand vielleicht ein Thema da. Hauptsache, man hat da keinen Ektikettenschwindel vollzogen. Leute, ich lege die Latte so, dass ihr drüber kommt. Okay, also Rens, sehr schön. Wir schauen, wo Worstil landet und ob er irgendwann in die Heimat zurückkehrt. Auf jeden Fall hochinteressante Trainer. Du hast es damals schon eingeordnet. Ich werde die alte Folge noch mal verlinken. Aber das Ganze mit dem Football-Manager wurde auch ein bisschen überstrapaziert. Er selber hat gesagt, na ja, ich habe schon auch noch andere Dinge gemacht.
Genau, die kommen anscheinend aus einer unglaublich, unglaublich fußballbegeisternden Familie. Ich glaube, seine beiden Brüder sind auch – mindestens der eine ist auch irgendwo Trainer.
Genau, ja. Also hat Fußball sehr früh wahrgenommen. Sehr schön. Dann schauen wir, was bei Rens passiert. Und jetzt schauen wir mal in La Liga. Alex darf uns mal was mitbringen. Ja, mit was willst du anfangen? Mit der Wohlfühlgeschichte oder mit dem, was wir schon angerissen haben?
Ja, gute Frage. Also ich habe natürlich zwei Storys. Champions League, weil drei Spanier dabei sind, ist die naheliegendsten offensichtliche, weil sonst nicht viel passiert ist. Vor allem nicht viel Spannendes in La Liga. Deswegen ist das zweite Thema streng genommen ja auch kein La Liga-Thema, denn es geht um den Copa del Rey-Triumph von Atletik Bilbao. Das ist die von dir angesprochene Wohlfühl-Story. Das wäre Story 2. Wir können gerne damit anfangen, weil es natürlich die schönere, besondere, glanzvollere Story ist. Auch wenn, wie gesagt, nicht per se eine La Liga-Story, denn das war ja der Pokal. Aber da hat Atletik Bilbao triumphiert nach 40 Jahren Leidens- und Wartezeit. Seit 40 Jahren warten sie darauf, endlich diesen Pokal zu gewinnen. Und sie waren ja sechsmal im Pokalfinale und haben sechsmal verloren. Und wer ihre Story so ein bisschen kennt, weiß, der Pokal bedeutet irgendwie in Bilbao scheinbar ein bisschen mehr als in anderen Städten. Sie sind ja auch der Vize-Rekordmeister hinter dem FC Barcelona. Ich glaube, jetzt 24-mal haben sie das Ding gewonnen. Und sie warteten eben 40 Jahre darauf mit sechs Niederlagen. Und deswegen, ja, er ist homegekommen sozusagen, die Copa del Rey, der Königspokal. Denn, ja, das war schon eine ganz, ganz besondere Geschichte, wie sie dann auch das oder nicht weniger Vizes gewonnen haben, dass sie das Ding gewonnen haben, wie sie gefeiert haben, was da so dahintersteckte für Stories. Schon eine besondere Sache, glaube ich, in Spanien.
Und das wurde auch in Spanien so aufgenommen, weil, also, ich habe auch Videos gesehen. Vor allem Tage danach noch. Ich dachte, das ganze Ding wäre durch. Und dann, aber irgendwie so vier Tage später, auf einmal eine riesige Parade. Ich dachte mir so, Moment, fallen die immer noch? Fallen die erst jetzt noch mal? Oder wie war das?
Beides. Also, man muss damit anfangen. Pokalfieler in Sevilla. Das haben sie ein bisschen so sich abgeguckt vom DFB-Pokal von Deutschland, wo Berlin der große Finalort ist. Sie haben es jetzt vor ein paar Jahren… Wisst ihr noch, warum das so ist in Deutschland?
EM 82. Ne, EM 82. Auf jeden Fall EM in Deutschland. Ne, Entschuldigung, 88. 88, dann die EM. Da wurde nämlich Berlin nicht Spielort und als Kompensation hat Berlin dann das DFB-Pokalfinale bekommen, das ja vorher immer in Köln war. So. Jetzt wieder du, Alex.
Cool. Ja, La Catouche ist quasi das Pendant dazu, also das Olympiastadion in Sevilla, das leer steht, wo eben kein Verein, keine Spiele stattfinden. Also hat der Verband sich quasi das Stadion als sein Stadion geschnappt, wo man eben nicht nur Länderspiele ab und zu ausübt, sondern wie gesagt das Pokalfinale dahin vergibt. Das macht es dann schon ein bisschen besondere, wenn nicht das Stadion jedes Mal wandert überall woanders, sondern dieser Sehnsuchtsort, La Catouche, Sehnsuchtsort Sevilla, das so ein bisschen Storytelling-mäßig aufgezogen wird, eben wie in Deutschland. Finde ich ganz nice, auch wenn das Stadion, passend zum Olympiastadion vielleicht nicht optimal ist, weil auch ein bisschen Laufbahn und so. Sei es drum, auf jeden Fall in Sevilla. Das Finale und das Schöne ist, der spanische Verband vergibt 40% der Tickets an die jeweilige Fanschar. Das heißt, das sind sehr, sehr viele Fans.
Also jeweils 40, also insgesamt 80% der Tickets.
Genau, und wer die UEFA kennt, da ist das ja ein bisschen anders beim Champions League.
20% über UEFA-Schnitt.
Genau, ich glaube, 20 oder 25% kriegt man bei der UEFA nur. Also da wird schon auch ein bisschen mehr an die Fans gedacht und etwas weniger an Sponsoren und andere Geldgeber und Wips, was es auch ein bisschen schöner macht. Und dann macht es ganz besonders schön, wie viele Fans da mitreisen. Die Rede ist davon, dass 100.000 Leute aus Bilbao in Sevilla dabei waren. Das ist wirklich absolut bemerkenswert. Ich habe jetzt nicht Hand nachgezählt, Handpicked, aber es waren sehr, sehr viele und die haben natürlich dann auch Tage vorher schon gefeiert. Am Freitag ging es los, am Donnerstag in den Bars. Also ganz, ganz besondere Szenen wirklich. Dieser Sehnsuchtsort, dieser Pilgerort mit einem besonderen Flair. Und dadurch ist das Finale irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen besonders aufgeladen. Jetzt war natürlich Mallorca, die sollen mit dem Schiff angereist sein, manche Fans, aber die haben natürlich jetzt nicht ganz so viele Fans mitgebracht. Aber irgendwie hattest du schon das Gefühl, da ist was Besonderes in der Luft. Und ja, dass dann der Athletik-Club aus Bilbao das Ding im F-Meter-Schießen gewonnen hat, war dann – also sie mussten ein bisschen leiden, sie lagen zurück, sie kamen zurück. Und dann war es endlich vollbracht nach 40 Jahren.
Aber wirklich. Und Bilbao, die Stadt selbst hat 340.000 Einwohner, das heißt 100.000 davon. Also kommen natürlich auch welche aus dem Umland schon klar. Aber das ist schon nicht so schlecht und war eine der schöneren Geschichten auf jeden Fall in dieser Saison. Das muss man so sagen. Und das Spiel war ein bisschen zäh, du hast es schon angesprochen, aber es wurde ja gewonnen und dann wurde auf besondere Art und Weise gefeiert.
Genau. Das Ganze heißt La Gabarra. Denn der Athletik-Club aus Bilbao feiert auf einem alten Kran, auf einem alten Frachtschiff oder irgendwie so ein altes Schiffchenlastschiff, glaube ich, oder wie man das nennen sollte. Ich bin jetzt nicht so kundig in dem Metier. Aber auf jeden Fall fahren sie da den Nervion-Fluss entlang, der durch die Stadt geht, am Guggenheim vorbei, an ihrem Stadion vorbei. Und die ganze Stadt ist auf den Beinen und feiert diese Mannschaft ganz, ganz besondere Szenen. Die Rede ist auch davon, dass insgesamt 120 Schiffe und Boote mit dabei waren. Also nicht nur das offizielle Boot von Athletik Bilbao, das schon vor 40 Jahren im Einsatz war. Also 1985, 1984, 1985 hatten sie das letzte Mal die Copa gewonnen, dann eben sechs Finalniederlagen und jetzt eben die traditionelle Feierei mit diesem Last-Shift, das eben schon damals im Einsatz war. Also auch eine ganz, ganz besondere Art zu feiern. Wirklich die ganze Stadt ist auf den Beinen. Wirklich krasse Szenen, auch schön. Ein Spieler, der gar nicht mehr bei ihnen spielt, war auch mit dabei. Inigo Martinez vom FC Barcelona, da haben sie in Paris gespielt. Man weiß es ja im Hinspiel. Dann ist er direkt nach Bilbao geflogen, hat da mit denen Party gemacht, war selber auf einem Schiff dabei. Da sieht man schon diese Verbundenheit von Spielern, von Ex-Spielern mit dem Verein. Die ganze Stadt ist ja eine One-Club-Story. Ein One-Club-Verein oder One-Club-City, so heißt es richtig. Dass da wirklich die Stadt und der Verein so eine Gemeinschaft, so eine Community sind. Ganz, ganz besonders. Vielleicht ein bisschen mit Leads vergleichbar, wo Uli da ist, wo wirklich eine Stadt einen Verein so dermaßen lebt. Ganz, ganz besondere Geschichten.
Möchtest du uns veranleuten, die umstrittene Parade zu den Olympischen Spielen von Paris 2024 auf der Szene ist von Bilbao geklaut?
Oh, das würde ich mir nicht anmaßen wollen, irgendwelche Parallelen ziehen zu wollen. Auf jeden Fall, die feiern das wirklich auf historische, traditionelle Art und Weise. Das bedeutet den Spielern so, so viel. Und einfach die Szenen zu sehen, da gab es, glaube ich, ein wunderschönes Bild. Freunde hatte, glaube ich, einen Artikel da. Im Guardian gibt es von Sid Lone einen ganz, ganz tollen Artikel dazu. Also wer das noch nicht gelesen hat, so mit Hintergrundstories und wie es so abgelaufen ist, gerne da mal reinlesen. Lagabara, die Bootsfahrt quasi. Sehr, sehr schöne Sache.
Aber wirklich sehr schön. Und es sieht ja auch in der Liga ganz ordentlich aus für Athletik. Also sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf den sechsten Tabellenplatz. Das heißt, aktuell fünfter ist man. Das ist ja eigentlich alles völlig im Soll, oder?
Ja, die haben jetzt dann fünf Tage übrigens gefeiert. Also es wurde schon vorher ein bisschen gefeiert. Teilweise Ika Munirin, der Kapitän, am Freitag, glaube ich, schon brachen Feierlichkeiten in der Stadt aus. Und am Samstag, wie gesagt, die große Parade. Und am Sonntag mussten sie dann spielen und waren dem Vernehmen nach nicht alle ganz fit. Deswegen war das Spiel ein bisschen übersichtlich, sondern nicht mal, also ja, plätscherte vor sich hin. Dann gingen sie 1-0 in Führung. Und haben natürlich den Pokal präsentiert, ihren Fans vorher, nachher. Tolle Feierstimmung. Und dann gab es aber in der Nachspielzeit einen, so muss man sagen, wirklich lächerlich falschen Handelfmeter. Also Spieler gerät strein, blockt den Ball mit dem Fuß, von seinem Fuß prallt er an den Arm. Und dann gibt es Elfmeter in der 95. Also furchtbar schlimmer Pfiff. Und dann nur 1-1. Den Feierlichkeiten, ja, die hat das ein bisschen gedämpft, war jetzt nicht so tragisch, aber mit Blick auf die Champions League ist das eben ja ein unschöner Rückschlag. Und in dem Fall, weil es wirklich eine schiedsrichter Fehlentscheidung war, war es ein bisschen bitter für den Athletik-Club auszubauen. Eine schöne Randnotiz, aber wer ist Trainer von Villareal? Der Gästemannschaft Marcelino, der Ex-Coach vom Athletik-Club de Bilbao. Und dass der dabei war, war für ihn auch eine besondere Sache. Der hat teilweise mit den Tränen ein bisschen gekämpft nach dem Spiel, weil es ja seine Ex-Mannschaft ist und hat auch gesagt, wie stolz er darauf ist. Und dass es so ein bisschen Schicksal war, dass er am Tag des Gewinns, dass er dabei sein darf als Gästecoach, ist irgendwie Schicksal oder passt ins Bild. Und man hat ihn ganz besonders mitgenommen. Also auch da sieht man mal, das war schon was Besonderes, dass der Ligaclub dieses Ding gewonnen hat. Silvo Garfield, Gästetrainer.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin großer Fan davon. Feier, Samstag, ja, komm, klar, spielen wir am Sonntag wieder. Nee, nee, wir sagen das, ihr müsst nicht verschieben. Das wird schon, das finde ich alles sehr, sehr gut. Und dann hätten sie eigentlich auch gewonnen. Also, das war ein wichtiger Pokaltriumph. Und unser persönlicher Triumph ist, dass Uli Hebel jetzt hier mit dabei ist. Alex hat es schon angekündigt. Aber jetzt bist du zu sehen. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich grüße euch.
Ja, du kannst dir noch kurz deine Themen zurechtlegen. Wir werden nämlich noch über die Serie A sprechen. Und dann bin ich sehr gespannt, was du uns heute so mitgebracht hast. Bernie, mit was willst du beginnen? Ja, es gab am Wochenende in Italien ja einen Schockmoment, der Gott sei Dank glemptflich ausgegangen ist. Und ja, über den würde ich ganz gerne sprechen, weil es eben um mehr ging als nur die Szene um Evan Ndicka. Die meisten haben es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen. Die Roma war am Sonntag in Udine zu Gast bei Udinese. Und in der 70. oder 71. Minute ist Evan Ndicka ohne Fremdeinwirkung von allein zu Boden gesunken. Er hat sich auch sofort an die Brust gegriffen. Und ja, Gott sei Dank haben alle wunderbar schnell reagiert. Die Notärzte waren sofort da. Man hat auch die Spieler sofort gesehen, die sofort auf dem Feld verstanden haben, dass da was potentiell Schlimmes passiert ist. Und Daniele De Rossi, der Roma-Trainer, war auch von Anfang an, würde ich sagen, genau das richtige Auge dafür gehabt, war sofort bei seinem Spieler. Dann gab es erst mal echt ein paar Minuten, wo man nicht genau wusste, wie es aussieht. Und dann gab es Gott sei Dank diesen positiven Momenten, Ndicka ist dann sozusagen runter transportiert worden und kurz vorm Kabinentrakt quasi hat er den Daumen nach oben gereckt. Und das war ja logischerweise in erstem Moment das allerwichtigste, auf das alle im Stadion gehofft haben. Aber ich finde, dann geht die Geschichte eigentlich nochmal wirklich los. Man hätte dann ja vielleicht auch sagen können, gut, Daumen hoch, er kommt jetzt nach hinten, wird behandelt und wir spielen jetzt einfach weiter, weil das logisch auch gerade für die Roma ein sehr wichtiges Spiel Richtung Champions League-Qualifikation ist. Aber da muss ich sagen, müssen wir jetzt nochmal über Daniele De Rossi reden. Und das ist so das nächste positive Puzzleteil, das sich jetzt über De Rossi den letzten Monaten einfügt. Also wie er die ganze Situation übernommen hat und moderiert hat, muss ich wirklich sagen, Chapeau, er ist sofort zum Schiri, hat gemeint, hat darum gebeten, dass er bitte jetzt auch noch in die Kabine rein kann, um sich auch wirklich zu vergewissern, dass es seinem Spieler gut geht. Hat ihm doch Schiri logischerweise zugestanden. Er ist nach innen, Mancini ist auch mit, einer der Spieler, Roma, einer der Führungsspieler. Dann hat es auch länger als ein paar Minuten gedauert. Als er wieder rauskam, war auch alles abgesprochen mit dem Udinese-Trainer, mit Shofe Balzaretti, der Sportdirektor von Udinese, ein ehemaliger Teamkollege von Rossi bei der Roma. Die haben sich gleich super miteinander ausgetauscht. Als er wieder rauskam, hat auch noch kurz der Rossi mit seinen Spielern gesprochen und hat dann zum Schiedsrichter gemeint, wir sehen uns nicht in der Lage, weiter zu spielen. Der Schiedsrichter hat das auch wunderbar gelöst. Man hört auch ein paar über die Außenmikros, hat man gehört, dass er schon beiden Trainern gesagt hat, ihr entscheidet, was hier passiert, wie es weitergeht. Wie gesagt, der Rossi hat das in die Hand genommen. Im Prinzip hat man sich dann ohne große Diskussion darauf geeinigt, dass das Spiel hier abgebrochen wird. Das Stadion hat wirklich auch sehr gut reagiert. Man hat auch sofort gespürt im Stadion, dass allen bewusst war, dass da ja was potentiell Dramatisches passieren hätte können. Deswegen würde ich sagen, also initiiert von der Rossi, der wirklich eine hohe Sensibilität hier einen Tag gelegt hat, und aber auch zusammen mit den Verantwortlichen von Odinese haben sie das meines Erachtens nach im allerbesten der Fälle gelöst. Und jetzt muss man ein bisschen die Einordnung auch noch treffen, denn das war der Jahrestag, 12 Jahre zuvor, 2012, Pier Mario Morosini, vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar, das waren Zweitligaspieler, und der ist auf dem Feld zusammengebrochen und gestorben. Und das war genau 12 Jahre davor, und Morosini hatte auch eine Vergangenheit bei Odinese. Also da ist eine, ich würde schon sagen, in Italien ist es ähnlich vielleicht auch wie in Spanien, mit dem Fall Puerta, da ist eine hohe Sensibilität diesem Thema gegenüber, und man hat halt bei der Rossi noch gemerkt, dass er da noch sehr als Spieler gedacht hat, und wirklich sozusagen, dass da Gedanken primär im Zentrum standen, die weg vom Fußball gingen, oder die wichtiger sind als auch der gespielte Fußball. Und die tragische Note, die da noch dazu kam, am selben Tag an diesem Sonntag ist in der Toskana ein Amateurspieler auf dem Feld zusammengebrochen und am nächsten Tag verstorben, der wirklich genau das selbe Prinzip. Und das Tragische daran, das waren der Bruder des Schwagers von Mancini, also der Roma-Spieler, der sozusagen am selben Tag das mit Ndicka miterlebt hat, hat dann am Tag danach erfahren, dass sozusagen der Bruder seines Schwagers, ein Amateurspieler, bei genau so einem Fall gestorben ist. Also da sieht man, ja, Fußball ist wichtig, aber es gibt halt Geschichten, die sind viel, viel wichtiger. Und ja, um jetzt das Ganze positiv abzuschließen, Ndicka ist ins Krankenhaus gebracht worden für nähere Untersuchungen, denn die erste Vermutung war oder erste Befürchtung, dass er einen Herzinfarkt gehabt hätte. Das konnte dann ausgeschlossen werden. Er hat die Nacht dann noch verbracht, konnte dann aber am nächsten Tag das Krankenhaus verlassen. Die ganze Mannschaft ist auch direkt nach dem Spiel zum Krankenhaus. Die Roma hat auch ihren Rückflug sozusagen erstmal alles anders organisiert. Der Rossi Pellegrini, die Kapitäne sind dann auch zu ihm rein ins Zimmer. Und die nächste Spieler, Kameraden, Nationalmannschaft, der Kollege von ihm, der war anscheinend den ganzen Abend bei ihm. Und am nächsten Tag gab es eben Entwarnung. Es war kein Herzinfarkt, es war ein Thorax-Trauma. Man sieht auch davor im Spiel, und daran sieht man vielleicht, deswegen wollte ich die Geschichte auch mitbringen, auch mehr als nur ein Moment, dass auch wenn es nicht dieses schlimme Herzthema war, vor dem alle in dem Moment Angst hatten, denn jetzt haben sich jetzt auch viele Mediziner in Italien zu Wort gemeldet. Sie haben gesagt, man darf halt auch nie außer Acht lassen. Der Fußball wird immer physischer. Und man sieht im Spiel auch, es gibt ein paar Szenen, wo ein Dicka auch Schläge auf den Thorax-Bereich bekommt. Einfach bei normalen Zweikämpfen. Genau, genau. Und die meinten eben auch, daran sieht man halt auch, durch die hohe Intensität heute kann sowas halt auch ausgelöst werden, auch wenn vielleicht gar nicht erst das Herz sozusagen, wie soll man sagen, in Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird oder wurde. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, ja, eine potenziell schlimme Geschichte, die gut ausgegangen ist. Es gibt Mediziner, die sagen, Ndicka kann vielleicht auch schon diese Saison noch spielen. Wird jetzt erstmal ein paar Tage in Ruhe logischerweise bekommen. Aber die Herzwerte sind alle total im grünen Bereich. Und ja, um das Ganze vielleicht noch abzuschließen, das Spiel wurde im Minute 72 abgebrochen und jetzt wird es auch genau, das Regen, die Regularien genauso fest, wird genau da weiter gespielt. Jetzt geht es noch darum, den Termin zu finden. Das hängt noch ein bisschen davon ab. Vasti Roma, die ja heute am Donnerstagabend gegen Milan noch das Europa League Viertelfinal-Rückspiel hat. Aber auch da wird sich ein Termin finden lassen. Also nochmal Daniele de Rossi, der nächste bemerkenswerte Moment in seinen ersten bemerkenswerten Monaten als Cheftrainer in der Serie A. Aber wirklich. Und nachdem wir das alle, glaube ich, auch mitbekommen haben, es lief so ein bisschen parallel zum Meisterfeier in Leverkusen. Das war ein bisschen bizarr. Quasi zwei so sehr unterschiedliche Themen, die nahezu parallel zu einander passiert sind. Finde ich schön, dass wir es hier auch nochmal aufgearbeitet haben. Ist schwer zum Sportlichen zurückzukommen, aber andererseits ja gut, dass uns immer wieder klargemacht wird. Der Sport ist nicht das Allerwichtigste. Vielleicht kann man dann auch mit dem Ausscheiden in der Champions League besser umgehen. Ich weiß es nicht. Uli, worüber würdest du denn gerne reden? Positiv oder negativ?
Wir lassen die Champions League beiseite, hoffe ich. Weil das ist mir zu negativ gewesen am gestrigen Abend. Ich war sehr enttäuscht, muss ich echt sagen. Von beiden englischen Vertretern war ich sehr, sehr, sehr enttäuscht. Insbesondere von Arsenal. Weil ich das richtig gesehen habe. Und ich habe letztes Mal hier erzählt, dass sie gut sind und dass man die sich anschauen sollte und könnte.
Das habe ich direkt zu allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch vor dem Spiel erzählt, die zum Teil sehr selbstbewusst an dieses Spiel rangegangen sind. Gut, Bayern hat sie jetzt auch nicht an die Wand gespielt. Das hat mich dann gerettet hinten raus.
Ich glaube, dass es letztlich das Cleverste, was Tuchel gemacht hat, sich nochmal an Jesse zurückerinnert. Einfach wirkliches Aushalten zu Hause, umzuschalten. Das war sehr zuträglich der Sache, glaube ich. Aber ich kann es erklären, glaube ich, dass das, was Arsenal nicht so liegt, ein junges Team ist. Erstes Mal Viertelfinale miteinander. Man hat ihnen angemerkt, Nerven und so. Aber ich war trotzdem sehr enttäuscht, würde ich sagen.
Ja, Martin Ödegard auch. Ich konnte selber keine Frage stellen. Die englischen Kollegen waren da sehr schnell. Und da ist es ja so, der Pressesprecher kommt mit und sagt dann so, jetzt noch 2 Questions und dann ist aber auch wirklich Schluss. Und dann ging schon das interne Hauen und Stechen los. Aber der wurde ja mehr oder weniger in Manndeckung genommen von Konrad Leimer. Das habe ich auch noch mit Konrad Leimer drüber gesprochen. Und der meinte so, ja, ist schon irgendwie besonders, weil ich muss irgendwie Sechsers spielen und trotzdem immer gucken, wo der ist, weil ich ihn eigentlich immer verfolgen muss. Aber es hat ganz gut geklappt. Und Ödegard war aber so komplett, der war richtig desillusioniert. Und der hat aber auch keinen einzigen inhaltlichen Satz gesagt, ehrlich gesagt. Der hat alles gesagt, was erwartbar ist. Ja, wir müssen jetzt weitermachen, wir haben immer noch was zu gewinnen. Und natürlich sind wir enttäuscht. Wir müssen es aber erstmal analysieren. Also, was soll er auch sagen? Aber der war so fast ein bisschen konstelliert, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Jaja, also der war auch nicht ganz fit. Also war er lange ein Fragezeichen für das Spiel. Das sind aber genau die Dinge, die ihm immer noch fehlt. Ich glaube, wir haben ja hier auch mal gesprochen als MVP über ihn, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Das sind die Dinge, die ihm noch fehlen, dass er, wenn es Mann gegen Mann geht, noch nicht so gut klarkommt. Und er hat noch zum Teil Probleme gegen eine gewisse Körperlichkeit auf Mid-Block-Niveau. Also wenn Newcastle oder so es kommt, dann geht noch. Aber gut, wollen wir uns den Tag nicht versauen mit solchen Dingen?
Ach so, ich glaube, die Bayern-Fans, die könnten dich noch ewig über Arsenal reden hören.
Ja, aber das macht doch den Triumph auch nicht schöner, oder? Also wie Liverpool auch. Arsenal hat sich jetzt in einer Woche die ganze Saison eingerissen. Weil jetzt geht es wieder los. Und das war schon spürbar gegen Villa am Sonntag. Dass Ateta Hektischer wird draußen, nicht so ruhig in den Bewegungen und Ansagen. Das merkt man bei ihm sehr, sehr schnell. Da muss er noch, glaube ich, stark daran arbeiten, weil das einfach zu leicht zu entziffern ist, wann es bei denen losgeht. Und da haben sie sich auch hinten raus auskontern lassen. Gegen genau das Gleiche. Also Thomas Tuchel wird nur am Sonntag Premier League geguckt haben und wird sich gedacht haben, wir werden schon sehen, ob ich das nicht auch hinlege.
Das ist die eine Sache, die wir auch können. Ja, ein bisschen so. Und ich meine, Ateta hat ja auch wieder was probiert. Er stellte einen Spieler auf, der irgendwie zuletzt im Dezember, glaube ich, in der Startelf stand, lässt Martinelli spielen, der ja eigentlich noch mit einer der Besten war. Aber das war alles offenbar mit dem Blick, wie nehmen wir Saneh raus. Ja, einer der Besten auf niedrigem Niveau. Aber die einzigen Offensivaktionen. Saka war komplett rausgedoppelt von den Bayern. Und letztlich hat er genau dasselbe mit Saneh machen wollen. Hat auch funktioniert, bis auf eine Szene. Also zweimal kommt Saneh vorbei. Jeweils auf der rechten Seite, interessanterweise, nicht über den linken Cut. Zweimal kommt er vorbei. Einmal geht er in die Grundlinie, passt noch in, wird geblockt zur Ecke. Und das andere Mal ist dann die Flanke mit rechts. Die Raya auch in seiner ganzen Raya-Artigkeit mit einer Hand noch im Spiel hält, anstatt vielleicht mit zwei Händen oder sonst wie. Und dann schieben sie halt nicht drauf auf Gereo.
Ja, und auch das ist schade, weil die haben insbesondere im Kalenderjahr 2024 diese Defensive ja nichts zugelassen, gar nichts. Nicht mal gegen City. Also die sind in zwei Saisonspielen gegen Manchester City mit zwei Torschüssen rausgegangen. Das ist unglaublich. Aber ich hoffe, ich botch es jetzt nicht, aber vielleicht waren es auch drei. Aber auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr, sehr geringe Anzahl und im Rückspiel ja gar nichts mehr zugelassen. Und den Gabriel, den du gestern gesehen hast, den habe ich jetzt am Sonntag auch schon gesehen. Aber davor halt einfach monatelang nicht mehr. Deshalb habe ich mich ja hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, okay, ich habe den immer stark kritisiert und bin nie davon ausgegangen, dass es wird mit dem. Und habe gesagt, okay, gut, offensichtlich habe ich mich getäuscht. Der ist legit.
Da sind wir wieder.
Das ist jetzt dieses Segment, wir wollen nicht über Champions League reden. Aber tun wir später. Hoppla.
Wenn ich kurz reingrätschen darf, weil ihr gerade hier so ein bisschen Lobgesänge macht auf Tuchel, das hat die Süddeutsche nämlich auch geschrieben. Tuchels Meisterleistung führt die Bayern ins Halbfinale, ist, glaube ich, die Überschrift unter einem Artikel.
Du, das haben auch…
Nachdem du jetzt im Stadion warst, Max, würdest du das auch so nennen, eine Meisterleistung.
Sie haben gut verteidigt und sie haben das gemacht, was sie können. Sie können ja keinen Ballbesitz gegen tief stehende Gegner, aber zum Beispiel Aufbauspiel… Also in der ersten Hälfte waren die noch, die wollten halt beide keinen Fehler machen. Und das finde ich auch akzeptabel. Das ist ja richtig, weil wenn die irgendwie nur zwei hinten liegen in der ersten Hälfte, sitze ich hier und sage, wie seid ihr denn dieses Spiel angegangen? Aber habt ihr ein Muster gesehen, wie sie sich im Aufbau gelöst haben? Ich nehme ja auch nicht. Einmal Goretzka hat mal abgekippt, Leimer ist abgekippt, sie haben es konventionell gespielt, sie haben es über Neue gespielt. Aber es war alles… Und dann habe ich Konrad Leiber gefragt. Der hat da auch interessanterweise… Der hat mal auch ein paar Sachen gesagt. Und der hat auch… Weil ich habe gesagt, ihr habt es ja eigentlich dann immer nur geschafft… Oder sie, ich sieze ihn ja. Das ist über Triplings dann ging, dass ihr so den Aufbau geschafft habt. Pass, pass, pass, pass, pass. Und dann kann einer aufdrehen und dribbeln. Und so ist ja auch letztlich das Tor entstanden. Dann hat er gemeint, ja, genau so war so ein bisschen der Plan. Natürlich nicht nur. Wir hätten es auch über den Pass gelöst. Aber es ist extrem schwierig, weil die so mannbezogen draufpressen. Er hat da auch Arsene sehr gelobt. Und dann musst du halt darauf hoffen, dass die irgendwann müde werden. Und das ging ja irgendwann. Und dann hat das ein bisschen besser funktioniert. Dann dachte ich mir so, ja, völlig legitim, alles in Ordnung. Aber ob ich das als Meisterleistung bezeichnen würde und ich weiß, wo das herkommt, weil es waren Dresen, Heiner und Eberl in der Mixed Zone. Und die haben halt alle, also Thomas Tuchel, Trainergott und was für ein tolles Schachspiel und was für eine tolle Idee von ihm. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, Julian Nagelsmann, ja, machen wir jetzt dann klar die nächsten Tage. Aber wir sagen natürlich offiziell nichts dazu. Also, es war der FC Bayern in seiner ganzen FC Bayern Haftigkeit. Das tut mir leid, ich kann es nicht anders sagen. Und dass dann die Medien drauf anspringen, es ist ja richtig, es war ja gut. Aber ob das jetzt eine taktische Meisterleistung war? Also, wenn Uli sagt, dass Aston Villa genauso gegen Arsenal gespielt hat. Und jetzt will ich nicht Aston Villa kleinreden. Aber dann ist ja auch nicht Tuchel jetzt nicht da auf eine besondere Idee gekommen, oder Uli?
Nee, das ist ja auch nichts ganz Neues. Also, die einzigen Möglichkeiten, die es in der Saison gab, nicht zu verlieren gegen Arsenal, waren genau diese Dinge gemischt mit deren Jugendhaftigkeit, die ja einfach nur mal da ist. Das kann man ja nicht wegdiskutieren. Ja, das war okay von Bayern. Ich würde in dem Fall aber ehrlich gesagt mich nicht hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, das war Bayern, sondern das war die Schwäche Arsenals, die eigenen Unzulänglichkeiten und nicht mal Schwäche. Und ja, dann ist es halt tuchelortanistisch genug gewesen, zu sagen, okay, das halte ich jetzt mal aus zu Hause, mich aufs Wesentliche, aufs Reagieren zu konzentrieren. Ich bin gespannt, ob das noch einmal so geht, weil dann haben sie auch da eine gute Möglichkeit in der Theorie. Und dann sind sie in London. Aber das hat eher mit Arsenal zu tun und deren Problemen, die die haben, als mit Bayerns in Anführungszeichen Stärke, die ich nämlich auch nicht wahrgenommen habe. Also das ist immer noch sehr, sehr, wie soll man sagen, kleinere Versatzstücke eines jeden Einzelnen zusammengepresst bei Bayern. Also ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass da eine Mannschaft nach Plan zusammen Fußball spielt. Sondern das sind halt einzelne Angriffe, die man so im Umschalten fährt. Und das ist fair enough, wir sind im Halbfinale, aber da stehen auch andere Teams.
Ich habe jetzt gerade extra mal kurz nachgeschaut. Also L'Equipe übertitelt den entsprechenden Artikel mit Bayern und Tuchelhütten. Ihr Savoir faire, Europäer eingesetzt. Ihre Erfahrung in Europa, ihr gewusst wie in Europa. Aber ich halte das auch eher für ein bisschen Fußballorakeln, ehrlich gesagt. Das sind so diese Flossen.
Tatsächlich war natürlich die Erfahrung und die Haltung zu diesem Spiel auch schon im Hinspiel. Arsenal hat eine fantastische Anfangsphase, muss höher führen als 1 zu 0. Und dann konnte er die Bayern zweimal und du siehst, wie ganz Arsenal anfängt zu überlegen, inklusive Zuschauer. Ohje! Und diese Phasen hattest du jetzt im Spiel in München schon auch.
Und ich sag dir was, mit dem Moment, als die angefangen haben nachzudenken, haben sie die ganze Saison versenkt. Weil genauso haben sie sich gegen Esten Villa angestellt am Sonntag und genauso sind sie ins Spiel schon reingegangen. Mein Bruder war auch da im Stadion, ich hab's mir gespart gestern. Und der hat mir auch gesagt, guck dir mal die ersten 20 Minuten nochmal an. Da wirst du sehen, wie die, selbst wenn es Lücken gegeben hätte, nochmal drauf gestiegen sind und nochmal quer gepasst haben. Sicherlich auch aufgrund der Sichtverhältnisse, um einfach keinen Fehler zu machen. Aber da war schon so eine Grundnervosität dann spürbar, dass sie auf Krampf in Kontrolle kommen wollen und dabei aber den Flow vergessen. Und das ist das, was Arsene Annalie ausgezeichnet hat. Und ich hab gestern, gibt's ja noch viel Helme und so, da schreiben dir dann Leute bei X oder so, ja, hast du deine Premier League und sowas. Und war ja klar, dass das nur eine glorifiziertes Team ist. Ja, genau.
So schlecht ist sie doch gar nicht, wie du das immer sagst.
Super. Und dann gab's natürlich Leute, die gesagt haben, ja, das ist sehr klar, in der Premier League könnte ich das auch und so. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde sogar, die Premier League ist deutlich schwieriger, weil da kriegen die regelmäßig solche Spiele und sie sind durchmarschiert und haben aber, das war der Unterschied, aus der Kontrolle heraus den einen vernünftigen Ball gespielt und haben sich dann noch relativ effizient gezeigt. Und wenn es da nicht ging, wenn es wirklich mal überhaupt nicht ging, dann sind sie geduldig geblieben, bis sie eine Standardsituation hatten und dann ist es halt da reingefallen. Und auch das haben sie ja einfach nicht erspielt. Enttäuschend, ich glaube, dass diese Truppe und das ist das, was sie mitnehmen werden, das ist deren erste Champions-League-Saison, in der sie sich überdurchschnittlich nervös angestellt haben. Finde ich schon. Also auch in der Gruppenphase, das war nicht so besonders, aber das ist unglaublich wertvoll im Gesamten für das Lernen dieses jungen Kaders. Die sind ja eh total vor dem eigenen Plan. Und ich tippe auch, dass die weiterhin jetzt genau in der gleichen Art und Weise dazuholen, dazuverpflichten an Spielern. Hatten ja auch ungute Verletzungsgeschichten hier und da. Das ist jetzt besser geworden hinten raus, aber das ist das einzig Positive, was ich daraus mitnehme. Aber blöderweise, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, ich verfolge Bayern logischerweise auch qua Beruf, dann hat die bessere Mannschaft es raus in der Saison. Und zwar die deutlich bessere Mannschaft.
Genau, auf die Saison gesehen, aber nicht auf die Spiele gesehen.
Genau, da ist das völlig in Ordnung.
Ja, interessant. Mich hat das ein bisschen erinnert an die 1. Champions-League-Saison von Dortmund damals, als sie Meister geworden sind. Wo sie doch auch gegen Marseille in der Gruppe, glaube ich, verloren oder 2-2 irgendwie auch noch so spät Tore kassiert. Und da dachte ich mir so, ja, da war das damals auch so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, die müssen jetzt in diesen Wettbewerb reinkommen und müssen diese Nervosität ablegen, die du bekommst, wenn du wenig Chancen bekommst. Harry Kane hatte in der ersten Hälfte gegen Arsenal 9 Ballkunden. 9 Ballkontakte. Davon waren 5 irgendwie so, dass es noch eine Anschlussaktion gab. Also der war eigentlich nicht zu sehen. Aber du hast ihn in jeder Minute angemerkt, dass der sich die ganze Zeit gedacht hat, naja, ich mache heute noch eins. Ich meine, da hat er sich geirrt, er hat keins gemacht. Aber der hat sein Spiel exakt so weitergemacht. Und Ödegaard zum Beispiel ist richtig nervös geworden irgendwann, dass er nicht von Leimerlust kam und dass er nicht angespielt wurde, weil die keine Lust hatten, diesen Risikopass in die Mitte zu spielen. Und dann ist er links und rechts immer rausgedrittet aus dem Zentrum. Und im Zentrum war aber der Platz. Bayern ist immer in die letzte Kette ganz tief reingefallen. Wie gut wir jetzt nicht über die Champions League geredet haben, Uli.
Toller Moderator, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe ja wirklich alle Zyklen in der Hand. Das war übrigens sein erstes Thema.
Dann kürze ich Tottenham weg zu Gunsten Arsene. Da werde ich mich sehr beliebt.
Vielleicht haben wir ja noch Zeit. So etwas wäre bei 3.90 nie passiert. Ihr habt eure Themen immer im Blick, David. Da läuft es auch immer genau nach Redaktionsplan, das weiß ich. Deswegen, um jetzt wieder zurück in die Struktur zu kommen, muss ich dir das Wort für dein zweites Thema.
Ich habe erst noch einen Nachtrag zu deiner KTK-Frage zu liefern. Du hast dich recht mit dem Hinweis, er kommt aus Reims und hat auch eine Saison für dich gespielt. Ich weiß auch, dass er in dieser ersten Saison war. Da habe ich mich auch kurz verletzt. Aber du hast mich jetzt komplett auf den falschen Fuß erwischt, weil natürlich war er in der Saison davor schon an Paris ausgeliehen. Das war ja diese Sache, dass Paris nicht den schon – das Ungewöhnliche, die kaufen ihn nicht, sondern leihen ihn erst mal aus, obwohl eigentlich jeder weiß, dass er das große Teil des Landes ist. Und dann kaufen sie ihn. Und deswegen steht er noch offiziell – ich glaube, in den Transferlisten steht jetzt L. Rai von Reims nach Frankfurt oder wie auch immer. Irgendetwas wurscht, aber jedenfalls, ne, also der war schon in längstem Partie in Deutschland. Und hat dann da auch eine komplette Saison gespielt.
Weißt du, was mit dem war im ersten Halbjahr, warum der nicht durfte?
Ne, tatsächlich nicht.
Weil da gibt es wahnsinnig irre Mythen, die ich jetzt nie weiter verbreiten wollte. Aber nach meinem Wissen wissen sie es in Frankfurt auch nicht genau, was die Problematik war, warum er nicht mitmachen durfte, weder im Training noch im Spielbetrieb.
Nach dem, was ich gehört habe, war Ihnen das so auch nicht klar. Also dass er nicht quasi im Regelbetrieb mit dabei war, aber wie wenig er sich selber dann quasi fit gehalten hat, muss wohl doch eine Überraschung gewesen sein. Nächstes Mal Laktat-Test beim Medizin-Check machen. Wobei macht man eigentlich, glaube ich, das machen sie standardmäßig, glaube ich, mit. Na gut.
Gut, also, zweites Team, das ich mitgebracht hatte, war – ich dachte, wir schauen mal kurz nach oben, weil wenn wir nach oben schauen, dann sehen wir da eine Mannschaft, von der ich auch beim letzten Mal oder einer letzten Mal noch gesagt habe, dass sie eigentlich ziemlich angezählt ist, nämlich die AS Monaco von unserem Freund Adi Hütter. Die war extrem instabil die ganze Saison hinweg, so immer wieder mal. Ist im November gegen PSG mit fünf Toren untergegangen, hat im Januar gegen Besagtes RAS verloren, war auch bei den Siegen nicht so wirklich überzeugend. Also tauchten bereits so die ersten Fragen auf. Überlebt Hütter? Überlebt ist auch Fußball-Martial. Bleibt Trainer.
Du, gestern hat jemand in der Fernsehübertragung gesagt, das Stadion ist im sprichwörtlichen Sinne – nee, ist im wortwörtlichen Sinne explodiert. Da dachte ich mir, nee, wortwörtlich zum Glück nicht.
Man muss ein bisschen einschränken. Monaco ja hatte Verletzungs-Sorgen. Im Winter waren noch einige Leistungsträger beim Afrika-Cup und das zumindest hat sich alles gebessert. Die sind alle aktuell wieder zurück. Ich kann mal kurz diese Liste durchgehen an Offensivspielern, die Adi Hütter zur Verfügung hat. Also Wissam Ben Yedder hatte. Fullerin Balogun, das war der, den wir auch bei Reims letztes Jahr noch erwähnt hatten. Der war ja von Arsenal ausgeliehen. Alexander Golovin, der muss man auch sagen, mal kurz festhalten. Der spielt eventuell gerade seine beste Saison seit seiner Ankunft 2018. Ist ein unglaublich kompletter offensiver Spielmacher. Schießt Tore, Vorlagen, alles. Du hast Takumi Minamino. Du hast junge Leute wie Akliusz. Du hast, oder auch Benzir Gier. Und dann hast du einen Brel Embolo, der war auch lange lange verletzt. Ist jetzt wieder zurück. Du hast da richtig, richtig qual der Wahl. Und was macht Hütter jetzt? Er sagt, ich stelle die einfach alle auf. Ich dachte schon, die Antwort ist eine Spitze. Er packt da jetzt irgendwie so vier, fünf Offensive vorne hin. Und aktuell ist Monaco ein ziemliches Spektakel. Die haben jetzt weit besten Angriff der Liga mit 52 Toren. Aber auch die 11 schlechteste Abwehr. Es gibt immer was zu sehen gefühlt irgendwie. Aber es funktioniert. Er hat sich da jetzt hochgearbeitet. Sie stehen auf dem dritten Platz. Sie haben sogar ein bisschen Abstand jetzt vor Lille. Brest ist da immer noch oben. Da komme ich nachher nochmal kurz drauf. Aber ja, das ist in Ordnung. Wer man tatsächlich kurz erwähnen kann, ist Wilfried Singo, Afrikameister mit der Elfenbeinküste. 23 Jahre, kopfhaft stark, schnell. Er hat die Verteidigung sehr, sehr stabilisiert. Und einer der Gründe, warum ich kurz nochmal auf Monaco eingehen wollte, war auch, dass ein Artikel erschienen ist von ein paar Wochen. Ich glaube, es war eine Likip. Da hat ein Journalist mal versucht, so ein bisschen das Leben in Monaco für Fußballspieler zu beschreiben. Und hat sich da auf großartigste…
Ist es hart. Müssen Sie jetzt Handflaschen sammeln?
Also er hat sich auf großartigste reportagige, lokaljournalistweise viele Anekdoten über Navi-Lebt-es-nicht-in-er-reichen-Stadt zu sammeln. Das sei ja für Fußballspieler schon so ein seltsames Gefühl, dass sie von Leuten umgeben sind, die noch viel reicher sind als sie. Also wenn du da zum Bürgeramt gehst und deinen Ausweis verlängerst, dann stehen da Novak Djokovic und Lewis Hamilton irgendwie mit dir in der Schlange. Angeblich haben irgendwie ein, zwei Leute erzählt. Und Leute würden dann sagen, ja, wenn du in Nizza, Lamborghini fährst, dann drehen sich die Köpfe nach dir um. Aber in Monaco stehen da einfach mehrere Dutzend Autos. Die sind teurer als deins. Sicherheit ist natürlich auch tatsächlich in Frankreich immer ein großes Thema. Wir hatten immer wieder auch nach wie vor Einbruchsgeschichten in Marseille, in Paris. Und das ist ja in Monaco alles ganz wunderbar. Da ist alles videoüberwacht. Die Polizei ist sehr präsent. Angeblich hätte ein Monakospieler in der Vergangenheit immer die Schlüssel an seinem Fernseher abregeln lassen. Das sei gar kein Problem. Und das sei ja alles auch so schön nah. Golovin geht immer zu Fuß nach Hause nach dem Spiel. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, die französischen Spieler profitieren ja nicht von dieser Steuerfreiheit. Also Monaco hat ja ein Abkommen mit Frankreich. Das heißt, die wiederum leben auf der französischen Seite, während Ausländer eben keine Einkommensteuer zahlen. Und ich weiß ja, Marc, auch du bist gerade auf Wohnungssuche. Also in Monaco zahlst du für eine 4-Zimmer-Wohnung 11.000 Euro im Monat. Und in den teureren Vierteln zahlst du für eine 3-Zimmer-Wohnung 17.000 Euro im Monat. Und es gibt nur einer als Supermarkt. Da trifft man angeblich Adi Hütter mit Einkaufswagen und Einkaufsliste in der Hand. Aber das Problem sei eben, es gibt insgesamt so wenig Ablenkung. Also manche Spieler schlagen dann, wenn es Ablenkung gibt, schnell über die Stränge. Ismael Jacobs hat Strafen bekommen, weil er rund um die Formel 1-Krumpi zu viel gefeiert hat. Und es wird dann ein Spieler zitiert mit den Worten, naja, sobald du am ersten Tag alle Boutiquen mal abklappert hast, gibt es dann nicht mehr viel in Monaco. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt, wie weit der Kollege dann doch ein bisschen über Bord gegangen ist, weil ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt in anderen Städten die Fußballer so viel mehr am sozialen Leben teilnehmen oder mehr machen als Boutiquen abklappern. Aber ich fand es einen sehr schönen Einblick in die Welt Monaco.
Und ich drücke jetzt Adi Hütter und seinem Team noch mehr die Daumen, dass es klappt mit der Champions League. Dann kommt man nämlich ein bisschen rum.
Da gibt es auch viele Boutiquen.
Und wisst ihr was? Ich war schon mal im selben Supermarkt wie Adi Hütter.
Das ist halt hier der Dasein.
Was kostet da der Liter Milch, Uli?
Ohne Witz, das war so krass. Also allgemein eine Portion Pommes, das habe ich mir noch gemerkt. 14 Euro, vor 5 Jahren, 2019 muss das gewesen sein, dass ich da war.
Immer Restaurant oder die TK-Variante im Supermarkt?
Nein, das war ein Imbiss. Da hat uns die Besitzerin noch gesagt, es ist nicht alles teuer hier. Es gibt auch Sachen, die sind in Ordnung.
Da habe ich gesagt, hier bin ich richtig, Pommes, 14 Euro, ok.
Irgendwann erzähle ich auch mal die Geschichte, als uns Ralf Gunnisch mit der gesamten Crew ins, glaube ich, teuerste Restaurant überhaupt eingeladen hat. Er hat sich leicht unbeliebt gemacht. Er hat eine Portion Spaghetti, glaube ich, 48 Euro gekostet oder so, weil 50 Gramm Kohlbrüder drin waren in der Carbonara. Also waren wir alle sehr glücklich mit.
Also er hat euch nicht eingeladen, sondern er hat gesagt, wir gehen da jetzt hin.
Nein, nein, er hat uns gesagt, komm, da gehen wir hin und hat dann…
Eingeladen.
Ach so, ich habe ja nur reserviert.
Das ist der St. Pauli-Live bei Bisschen Straße.
Liebe Grüße an Ralf, ich sehe ihn Samstag endlich wieder.
Ganz liebe Grüße, ja, wirklich auch zurück. Das ist sehr schön. Ändert mich an meine Zeit bei NEON, da gab es immer den Betriebsaufzug nach Davos und die Printredakteure konnten gar nicht verstehen, warum die Praktikanten und die Onliner nur die Pizza Margarita für 28 Euro bestellt haben. Nehmt doch das von du, das ist doch so gut. Ja, das sind 72 Euro, guten Hunger, wir bleiben mal hier drüben. Aber das ist was anderes. Sehr, sehr schön. Es fasert ein bisschen geradeaus. Vielleicht straffen wir uns ein bisschen damit. Also ich meine, ich habe Zeit, aber wir, glaube ich, sind – bei Alex müssten wir jetzt mal wieder vorbeikommen. Du hast schon ganz lange gefühlt nichts mehr gesagt, oder? Was hast du denn uns noch mitgebracht?
Vor nicht allzu langer Zeit haben sie ja auch Man City rausgeschmissen. Das hat auch Real Madrid geschafft. Achtung, schöne Überleitung. Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, ich bin auch bei der Champions League wieder angekommen. Da waren wir ja vorhin schon unfreiwillig bei Ullis Besprechung. Und ich würde auch gerne anknüpfen, weil wenn schon drei Spanier, die drei großen Spanier in der Champions League dabei sind, aber zwei rausfliegen und der eine schmeißt den Titelverteidiger raus, ist das, glaube ich, besprechungswürdig. Ich würde es so zusammenfassen, Frust bei Barca. Enttäuschung bei Atletico und Catenaccio Triumph von Real Madrid bei City.
Lass mal mit Barca gerne anfangen, weil ich weiß, die sind deinem Herzen auch am nächsten. Welche Diskussion gab es denn da jetzt nach dem Spiel noch hinsichtlich des nicht gegebenen Strafstoßes beim Foul an Gündoğan? Ich denke, die rote Karte ist unstrittig, oder?
Es gab Schiedsrichterdiskussionen, also Diskussionen über den Schiedsrichter und Beschwerden. Deswegen habe ich sie auch Frust getitelt. Da ist der Frust groß, weil sie natürlich eine Riesenchance verpasst haben. Das wissen sie alle selber und dann bist du ja erst recht frustriert. Sie sind besonders frustriert mit dem Schiedsrichter-Entscheidung. Also die A-Rauhe-Rote war ihnen zu hart oder zu wenig Fielmängerspitzengefühl. Die Gündogan-Szene war ja kein Elfmeter. Darüber kann man tatsächlich stark diskutieren. Als Schiedsrichter kannst du es vielleicht nicht richtig sehen. Also in Realgeschwindigkeit hätte ich auch nicht gepfiffen. Das sah für mich nach Gewollt von Gündogan aus, aber nicht irgendwie gefault. Aber in der Wiederholung siehst du schon, dass er hinten in die Füße läuft und in diesen berühmten Gehfehler, wie man im Fußballerdeutsch so sagt, bekommt. Und wenn ich diese Zeitlupe habe und der wahr hat, dann würde ich schon mal anrufen bei meinem Schiedsrichter und sagen, das war doch nicht so wenig wie gedacht. Also strittige Szene, knifflige Szene, bin ich ehrlich. Ich jetzt in Realgeschwindigkeit auch nicht gepfiffen. Aber mit Ansicht der Bilder würde ich mir vielleicht dann eher wünschen, dass man dann den Schiri da nochmal an den Bildschirm schickt. Und dann kann es natürlich anders ausgehen, also die Entscheidung. Und deswegen fühlte sich Barca da etwas benachteiligt oder ungerecht behandelt. Oder die Entscheidung war halt, wenn sie 50-50 waren, zugunsten von PSG. Und deswegen ja, ganz, ganz viel Frust bei Barca. Der Einzige, der so richtig, also Xavi hat auch wieder geledert, wurde ja auch wieder des Feldes verwiesen. Der wurde in der Saison so oft mit gelben Karten und roten Karten bedacht. Ich weiß nicht, was er da immer brüllt und schreit.
Diesmal hat er ja dem Schiedsrichter in Anführungszeichen nur gesagt, dass er sehr schlecht ist. Und dann musste er gehen. Das war ja seine Verteidigung. Ich habe doch nur gesagt, dass er scheiße pfeift.
Es ist wirklich auffällig, dass er ständig gelbe und rote Karten auch in der Liga bekommt. Also das zieht sich wie ein roter Faden. Vielleicht sollte man sich da auch mal ein bisschen hinterfragen. Aber nochmal, ich bin ja da nicht dabei gewesen an der Seitenlinie. Also ich kann ja nicht sagen, ob er nur laut war oder ob das eine rote Karte, rote Karten würdig ist, platzweise würdig. Aber es passt natürlich ein bisschen ins Bild. Der Frust ist einfach enorm auch bei der Mannschaft, beim Trainer natürlich. Ich glaube, es gab ja noch eine rote für, ich weiß aber nicht, welchen offiziell. Ob es sein Bruder war, der Co-Trainer, habe ich nicht ganz mitbekommen. Also ja, Frust groß und der Einzige, der quasi Tacheles geredet hat, ohne über den Schiedsrichter zu wettern, war Gündogan in seinem Interview. Er hat dann auch klar gesagt, du musst dich einfach besser anstellen. In Richtung Arauch, da kannst du nicht so hingehen. Da musst du dich klüger anstellen, da musst du den ablaufen, kannst nicht da an der Schulter ziehen. Du lädst ihn ja ein, den Spieler. Jeder, der Fußball gespielt hat und vielleicht eine Offensivposition hatte, weiß, wenn du da kreuzt und der kommt da wie so ein D-Zug angerauscht, dann weißt du, was dir der Verteidiger anbietet, und dann nimmst du das natürlich an, und der Verteidiger muss sich da klüger anstellen. Das ist jetzt auch kein 19-Jähriger mehr, Arauch. Also da hat Günter Ganschel auch gesagt, sie waren in den wichtigen Momenten zu ungestümt, zu unreif, zu unklug. Cancello, die Elfmeterszene, hatten ja trotzdem Chancen. Du hättest dieses PSG ja wirklich schlagen können, selbst in Unterzahl. Dann waren sie teilweise zu defensiv. Vor allem kurz nach der Halbzeit und vor der Halbzeit, obwohl sie es angesprochen hatten. Also eigene Fehler, eigene Unzulänglichkeiten. Und deswegen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen mit vermeintlich 50-50 Entscheidungen gegen sie. Und deswegen war der Frust enorm bei Barca.
Ja, das kann man auch verstehen wegen der vergebenen Chancen natürlich. Aber ich sehe es auch so wie du. Allein sportlich gab es da viele Dinge, die Barca nicht gut gemacht hat in diesem Spiel. Also eben zum Teil die Chancen. Ich meine einmal muss Lewandowski zum Beispiel noch abspielen. Sie sind auch irgendwann hektisch geworden in einer Phase, in der es nicht sein musste. Und eben auch solche Fehler. Also es war eben nicht Cubasi, der gerade erst 17 Jahre alt geworden ist, der diesen Fehler gemacht hat. Da hätte jeder gesagt, naja gut, das passiert halt einfach auf diesem Niveau. Sondern es war halt derjenige, der quasi ihm eigentlich so ein bisschen die Leitfigur sein sollte in diesem Spiel. So wie ja auch im Hinspiel ist der Fall, war. Und dann scheidest du halt auf diesem Niveau dann auch mal aus.
Ja, vor allem, da hast du da, also Günter Gann hat es ja auch gesagt, wenn du wegbleibst, zieht der Stürmer vielleicht weg. Barcola war es, der war schon im Hinspiel nach der Einwechslung so brutal stark, der war wieder der Gamechanger. Wie ich fand, selbst wenn er auf den Torwart zugeht, vielleicht hält ihn Testegen und selbst wenn er das Tor macht, dann steht es 1 zu 1. Wir sind ja trotzdem weiter. Also ein Gegentor ist ja nicht so schlimm wie, was waren es, 60, 70 Minuten in Unterzahl. Das ist ja immer die schlimmere Variante. Deswegen musst du so schlau sein als Fußballer und dann lässt du ihn halt ziehen. Vielleicht hält er das Ding und selbst wenn er ihn macht, ist ja nicht viel passiert. Das war einfach unreif, unklug. Deswegen umso frustrierender, weil es ja so unnötig war. Du hast das Hinspiel gewonnen und auch im Rückspiel. Selbst in Unterzahl hattest du ja 2, 3 richtig gute Chancen. Du hast gemerkt, wenn du offensiv spielst, wenn du draufgehst, wenn du mutig bist, dieses PSG ist zu knacken, ist wackelig. Vorne war PSG auch im Hinspiel, finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Aber gegen den Ball in Umschaltsituationen hast du gemerkt. Also bei 11 gegen 11 bin ich mir sicher, kommt der FC Barcelona weiter. Keine Frage.
Und ist Cubasi jetzt wirklich das nächste große Ding? Oder war das so, man hat das ja auch manchmal. Das ist quasi so, Oli Kirch hat auch mal in der Champions League ein ganz fantastisches Spiel gemacht.
Oli Hebel sagt ja und dem würde ich niemals widersprechen wollen.
Mein Crush, ich sage euch, wie es ist. Das ist ein sensationeller Fußballspieler. Das geht nicht, dass der unklar wird in der Birne. Ich glaube, wenn du mit 17 solche Auftritte hinlegst, dann habe ich das eher nicht. Wenn der gesund bleibt, dann geht es weit mit dem.
Generational Talents schreibt man immer auf Twitter und X. Und da bin ich hundertprozentig dabei. Ich habe das auch schon ein bisschen aufgeblasen, auch im anderen Podcast bei Tikitaka, aber ich wiederhole es gerne. Für mich das größte Innenverteidiger-Talent, das ich in der Altersklasse in meinem Leben gesehen habe, mir fiel da nur einer ein, der in so jungen Jahren wohl gemerkt hat. Es geht um 16, 17, 18, 19, diese Altersklasse, der da auf diesem Niveau so abgeklärt ruhig ist, alle Anlagen hat, wirklich alle, die es gibt. Mir würde vielleicht in jüngster Zeit die Licht einfallen, der ja sehr, sehr jung, auf sehr hohem Niveau spielte, aber ihre Division damals. Aber der war ja auch schon mit 18 Kapitänen, wo du gesagt hast, das ist das Komplettpaket, in so jungen Jahren.
Ganz, ganz, ganz andere Liga, also sorry, andere Liga.
Ich sage ja nur, der würde mir einfallen, dass ich sage, den packe ich irgendwie in so eine Kategorie, dass ich sage, boah, wenn der jetzt schon in dem Alter so reif ist, alles mitbringt, das kann einer werden, der ganz, ganz hochgeht.
Aber der ist doch schon, das ist aber der Einschub, den ich gerne noch machen will. Ich mache jetzt einfach einmal Werbung, ich habe dich noch gar nicht gefragt, aber ich verpflichte dich noch. Ich habe Flo Blüchel, der Scout, war bei Arsenal und bei Bayern. Schon gebeten, er möge den einmal durchleuchten, ob der genau mitgeht mit dem, was ich mache. Und dann machen wir einen BASA-Schwerpunkt nächste Woche bei RONDO TV.
Cubasi-Schwerpunkt?
Ja, den mache ich schon draus, keine Angst. Weil ich mit der These reingegangen bin, dass der Typ, das ist aber der Einschub, den ich gerne machen möchte. Selbst wenn der sich gar nicht mehr entwickelt, ist das schon nahe der Weltklasse, weil der alles hat. Aber der ist 17, also das heißt, der wird sich entwickeln. Und der hat halt genau die richtige Größe, glaube ich, fürs moderne Spiel. Der ist nicht klein, der ist aber auch – also nicht Lissandro Martinez klein, 1 über 1, 80 oder so, sondern der ist etwas größer. Der ist nicht super schnell, aber super clever, die Schnelligkeit auszunutzen. Das mag ich immer an Verteidigern sehr, sehr gerne, insbesondere Innenverteidigern. Wenn der in so einem jungen Alter schon eher reaktiv ist als proaktiv, dann ist das immer ein sehr, sehr gutes Zeichen. Das ist er definitiv. Aber in den richtigen Sequenzen – Timing ist das wichtigste Wort im aktuellen Fußball – in den richtigen Sequenzen ist er aggressiv. Und er hat den Touch eines Barcelona-Mittelfeldspielers. Das Barcelona ist in dem Fall dick zu unterstreichen. Er spielt die linienbrechenden Bälle. Die Zahlen sind komplett von einer anderen Welt, die er im Hinspiel aufgelegt hat. Die 3 Linien brechenden Bälle gegen Paris Saint-Germain. Die sind schon aggressiv.
Da gab es eine Grafik, die ich gesehen habe, dass er, obwohl er im März erst in der Champions League gespielt hat, jetzt schon die zweitmeisten linienbrechenden Bälle in der gesamten Champions-League-Saison hat. Der war in der Vorrunde gar nicht dabei in der Gruppenphase. Klar, diese 13 im Hinspiel, die blasen das Ganze auf statistisch. Aber wir atmen aus. Max, es tut mir leid, aber Uli ist schuld.
Ich bin da froh, dass ich diese Nachfrage gestellt habe. Ich fand ihn ja auch gut, aber ich wusste ja nicht, was ich hier los trete. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn. Ich war am Freitag am Rande eines Jugend-Trainings im Grünen Wald gesessen. Da gab es so einen Vater mit einem Pullover über die Schulter und so weiter. Und der hat jedem, wirklich jedem, da saßen so ein paar Mütter und andere Väter, der hat nur von Cubasi erzählt. Der hat immer noch gesagt, dass er 16 ist. Er hatte nicht mitbekommen, dass er gerade erst 17 geworden war. Aber der hat jedem erzählt, hast du das gesehen? Der hat Mbappé komplett aus dem Spiel genommen. Da dachte ich mir noch so, vielleicht ein bisschen zu begeistert von ihm. Aber jetzt, wenn ich Uli hier höre, hätte ich eigentlich sagen müssen, hier ist die Nummer von Herrn Hebel. Da könnt ihr gemeinsam einfach ein bisschen absuchten.
Ich komme mal nach Grünwald irgendwann, da hätte ich Spaß. Also ohne Witz, ich spreche, das wisst ihr hoffentlich selten, in solchen Superlative, insbesondere von jungen Spielern, weil es einfach nicht geht. Aber in dem Fall, als ich den das erste Mal gesehen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, wer zum Teufel ist das? Und wie geht das mit 17? Und nochmal, nicht nur weil er 17 ist, aber besonders weil er 17 ist. Echt super gut. Das ist so mein fußballerischer Crush. Ich wäre immer das gerne gewesen als Fußballspieler, wenn es nur ein halbes Prozent gewesen wäre.
Ich wäre auch gerne ein Spieler gewesen, der von dir so ist.
Man muss dazu sagen, Uli war Verteidiger, vielleicht ist er deswegen so verliebt.
Man muss kurz einschränken. Mbappé kommt nur zum Spiel nehmen, so schwer ist das nicht. Das hat sein Trainer auch gemacht. Und der sich selbst auch.
Jetzt beende ich hiermit die Pau Patrol.
Endlich. Pau Patrol ist super. Das ist sogar mir zu viel.
Wir müssen ja noch über Athletico sprechen. Was war denn zur Hölle mit Athletico los? Ich will es jetzt nicht kleinreden. Nein, liebe BVB-Fans, bitte lasst meine Inbox in Ruhe. Ich habe es ja verstanden. Es war ein gutes Spiel. Ich habe es nicht erwartet. Aber ich konnte nicht erkennen, Alex, was Athletico sich vorgenommen hatte. Ist das jetzt eine neue Entwicklung? Gibt es das jetzt schon häufiger, dass Athletico manchmal so ein bisschen lost wirkt in seinen Ansätzen?
Oder war das eine Ausnahme? Nein, das ist das Athletico, der diese Saison, vielleicht auch sogar, glaube ich, schon in der letzten Saison, das ist nicht mehr dieses Catenaccio-Athletico. Das kann Real Madrid wesentlich besser. Das haben wir in einem anderen Spiel gestern Abend im Etihad gesehen. Athletico-Spiele sind häufig wild. Häufig hat das verschiedene Geschichten. Nämlich, wenn Athletico früh presst, wenn Athletico draufgeht, wenn Athletico mit Selbstbewusstsein, mit Selbstvertrauen spielt, mit vielleicht auch einer Portion Verzweiflung oder Entschlossenheit, wie auch immer sich das speist, dann können sie jedem Gegner brutale Probleme machen. Grüße an Inter. Wenn sie aber in die Defensive fallen, wenn sie verwalten wollen oder wenn sie Angst haben, ihren Vorsprung zu verspielen oder wenn sie den verteidigen wollen oder warum auch was auch immer da psychologisch dahinter steckt oder taktisch, dann haben sie ein anderes Gesicht und sind schlagbar und sind auch von egal welcher Mannschaft wirklich schlagbar. Sie haben immer auch in einem Spiel verschiedene Gesichter. Sie verlieren ihren Faden. Mal finden sie ihn nicht, mal wollen sie ihn nicht, weil sie teilweise aktiv, absichtlich defensiv werden. Und dann sind sie hinten nicht mehr. Dieses Athletico der berühmten – was war das? 2013 bis 2016er Jahre, wo sie die Bayern zum Beispiel rausgeschmissen haben, wo sie zweimal im Champions League-Finale waren. Da war es immer basierend auf der Defensive, auf der Grundsoliden, auf dieser bissigen Abwehr. Das haben sie jetzt nicht mehr. Sie sind offensiv wesentlich besser. Das hat man jetzt auch gesehen. Sie haben zweimal im Rückspiel getroffen, im Hinspiel zweimal getroffen, hätten das Dritte machen können. Sie haben gegen Inter zwei oder drei Tore geschossen. Du hast gesehen, sie haben vorne gute Momente, aber hinten, das kriegen sie irgendwie nicht mehr so hin. Und dieses Athletiker der zwei Gesichter, das hast du gegen den BVB schon im Hinspiel gesehen. Da waren sie, weiß ich nicht, 50, 60 Minuten Ton angebend. Da kam der BVB gar nicht mit dem Pressing zustande. Und dann hatten sie ihr 2-0 und wurden reaktiv und defensiv. Und dann geben sie das Spiel aus der Hand, laden den Gegner ein. Und selbst ein BVB, der von allen Viertelfinale-Mannschaften, die mit Abstand schwächste war, findet im Metropolitano, wo sie erst ein Spiel verloren haben, Athletico in der Saison gegen Barca, finden sie ins Spiel und können ja fast den Ausgleich machen. Und dieses Athletico der verschiedenen Gesichter hast du eben im Rückspiel auch gesehen. Da waren sie plötzlich nach der Pause da und waren bissig und glauben an sich und haben Chancen und verballern die und machen die mal. Aber hinten kriegen sie es nicht so solide hin, dass sie über 90 Minuten das weg verteidigen können und werden ja auch teilweise wild. Und dann kann sich so ein wildes Spiel in beide Richtungen entwickeln. Mit Hin- und Rückspiel, wenn du es guckst. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, der BVB ist verdient weitergekommen oder war besser. Das war ein wilder Schlagabtausch, ein bisschen wie bei Barca gegen PSG. Und die eine Mannschaft, die ihre Chancen eiskalter machte, ist halt weitergekommen. Und wenn du an die Morata-Chance denkst und an noch irgendeinen in der zweiten Halbzeit, das sind 1000 Prozent, wenn du die machst, wenn du ans Hinspiel denkst, dass 3 zu 0 nach dem Standard am zweiten Pfosten den Kobel hält, der muss ja eigentlich auch drin sein. Dann könntest du sagen, Athleti kann das locker auch gewinnen. Aber in entscheidenden Momenten war der BVB halt eiskalter, abgezockter. So ist Athleti raus und ist natürlich enttäuscht mit sich selbst.
Eiskalt und abgezockt, das ist die Überleitung zur Real. Es geht jetzt gerade viral diese Gegenüberstellung von Pep Guardiola, der an der Taktik-Tafel völlig manisch irgendwie Laufwege zeigt. Und auf der anderen Seite eine Compilation von Carlo Ancelotti, der mit seinen Spielern tanzt. Und die Überschrift dazu ist irgendwie, der eine macht es über Taktik, der andere über Friendship, was ich ein sehr großes Wort finde in diesem Zusammenhang. Ist es denn wirklich so? Warum schafft das Real immer, immer, immer wieder?
Warum schaffen sie das? Weil sie diesen Glauben an sich selbst haben, komme es, was es wolle. Egal auf welche Art und Weise, wir halten das aus oder wir können das drehen. Vor zwei Jahren war es diese berühmte Glaube an sich selbst, dass man es noch drehen kann. Obwohl sie ja wirklich gegen PSG und City teilweise, also nicht nur hinten lagen, sondern auch wirklich die schwächere Mannschaft teilweise kaum stattfanden. Und dann haben sie es noch gedreht durch Glaube.
Die Saison des Klappstuhls.
War das die Saison? Nennt man das so?
Naja, da wird alle beide den Stuhl hoch.
Ich wusste nicht, dass das ein geflügelter Begriff ist.
Für mich immer im Kopf.
Und jetzt haben sie es eben auf eine andere Art und Weise gezeigt, indem sie sagen, wir können leiden, wir können das aushalten, wir können verteidigen, wir können auch 120 Minuten verteidigen. Das war ja wirklich Handball über fast 120 Minuten. In der ersten Halbzeit hatten sie auch noch gute Umschaltmomente, noch so 3, 4, 3 Mal dritt. Aber ansonsten standen sie ja nur hinten drin, aber haben das eben Atletico-esque verteidigt, die eben damals, als das so stark war, du erinnerst dich ja gegen die Bayern, da war ja, glaube ich, Atleti auch. 85 von 90 Minuten, nicht mal in der eigenen Hälfte, sondern ja teilweise im eigenen Strafraum. Und das war jetzt bei Real auch. Ja, aber was mit City los war, ich glaube, das könnte wahrscheinlich Uli dann besser erklären, warum die – das war ja gegen Arsenal schon der Fall, habe ich es ja auch gesehen – warum die so wenig Ideen haben, so wenig Inspiration, warum sie immer langsamer werden im Spiel, also nicht mehr diese Schnelligkeit in ihren Handlungsaktionen, in ihren Angriffsaktionen haben. Warum Haaland so gar nicht stattfindet, war gegen Arsenal ja das Gleiche. Ich glaube, weniger Ballaktionen als wahrscheinlich der Balljunge hinter dem Tor des Gegners. Also wirklich, ja, ganz, ganz besonders aber eben dieser Spirit der Champions League, diese Resilienz, die hat eben Real Madrid wie kein anderer Verein. Und die können weiterkommen auf verschiedene Art und Weisen, eben auch, indem sie einfach mal mauern, alles aushalten und dann im Elfmeterschießen die Ruhe behalten, während bei den anderen vielleicht die Nerven ein bisschen gehen oder der Frust größer wird, man den Faden verliert. Und real bleibt cool, selbst wenn sie nicht mal richtig viel Fußball spielen. Das war der beste Elfmeter von allen.
Der einzige kleine Letz von City tatsächlich. Und der letzte von Rüdiger war, also vor der Schussstärke kann man darüber diskutieren, aber platziert. Uli, magst du was zu City sagen oder hast du eh schon keine Laune mehr, nachdem wir so lange Asne gemacht haben?
Ne, auch enttäuschend. City, muss ich sagen, hat sich, wie Alex schon sagt, ein bisschen angekündigt. Ich kann es nicht erklären. Trotz der Ergebnisse, die im Moment ja gut sind in der Liga, ist auch da das Gefühl, irgendwann so ganz haut es nicht hin. Es ist oft die Einzelaktion, die es entscheidet. Und seltener der zusammengeklebte Spielzug, der es zumindest um diese Zeit letzte Saison geworden ist. Das war ja auch nicht alles Weltklasse. Bis zum Achtelfinale haben sie sich auch ganz schön gemüht. Ich weiß es nicht. Letztes Jahr um die Zeit weiß ich von einigen atmosphärischen Störungen, von denen ich jetzt nicht unbedingt berichten kann. Es gibt ein paar, die müde scheinen oder es wahrscheinlich auch sind. Es gibt ein paar, die nicht so ganz glücklich sind mit ihrer Rolle sozusagen. Es gibt in Track British zum Beispiel jemanden, der natürlich wahnsinnig wichtig war gerade in der Phase, weil er Leute auf sich gezogen hat in der letzten Saison und damit halt Räume geöffnet hat, der einfach gar nicht performt, einfach nicht gut drauf ist, der wohl auch ein paar mentale Probleme hat, nachdem im Dezember eingebrochen worden ist bei ihm. So hat das Guardiola immer wieder erklärt, hat ihn sich jetzt aber selber auch ein paar Mal gepackt schon auf dem Feld, weil es in manchen Fällen nicht genügend Aktivität gewesen ist. Doku finde ich relativ ausrechenbar, wenn auch schwierig zu verteidigen, aber auch vergleichsweise ausrechenbar. Und der lässt natürlich das Spiel schon oftmals einfach mit dem, wenn der den Ball bekommt, geht entweder das Eins gegen alle gut oder der Ball ist halt weg. Und das gibt es ja bei City so gesehen gar nicht. Also ich nehme weniger Spielkontrolle wahr und bei City heißt der Spielkontrolle automatisch immer Gegnerkontrolle, weil abseits des Balles wahnsinnig viel passiert. Aber da ist, du hast halt in Haarland jemanden, der eh nicht so Teil des Kombinationsspieles ist und wenn ein Doku auch noch kommt, dann ist er eh immer nur Hero Ball. Und das ist so strukturell das, was ich am ersten wahrnehme, was mir nicht ganz so gut gefällt. Aber da reden wir jetzt von zehn Prozent, das hätte, also bei allem Respekt für Real Madrid und den habe ich mehr als nur, weil das hat oftmals nichts mit Logik zu tun in der Champions League, warum die weiterkommen. Und das ist dann wieder eine gewisse Logik. Aber die hätten sie gestern schlagen müssen, also ohne Wenn und Aber.
Die Bräune hat diesen Elfmeter auf dem Fuß, also die Direktabnahme aus elf Metern glaube ich. Ich hau da drüber. Das war kurz nach dem 1-1, wenn du das 2-1 machst, ist das Spiel tot, dann ist Real Madrid weg. Weil Doppelschlag in der, keine Ahnung, 75. 78. ich weiß nicht, ob die sich davon noch erholen.
Wir nehmen ja gar nicht mal so sicher in der Saison.
Das sind halt Fine Margins. Das ist halt Champions League. Wir reden bei Basel darüber, bei Atletico, die Riesenchancen, Maurata 1 gegen 1. Das sind Fine Margins auf diesem Niveau zwischen diesen Weltklasse-Mannschaften. Und da kannst du dir keine Fehler erlauben, haben wir gesagt, und der Fehler ist da, der Bräune schießt halt übers halbe leere Tor. Das ist ein Fehler, der dich halt kosten kann.
Ja, und du hast aber schon, das fand ich schon gut, dass Uli das auch nochmal angesprochen hat, du hast dieses systematische Problem, dass Haaland nicht eingebunden ist. Also Uli sagt, er ist nicht Teil des Kombinationsspiels, wenn du dir die Passmap auf The Analyst anguckst, da gibt es nicht mal einen Strich zu ihm. City hat 920 Pässe gespielt, Haaland hat 7 Pässe gespielt. Der hatte 21 Ballkontakte. Also sprich, im Kombinationsspiel musst du nur 9 Feldspieler rausnehmen, nicht noch den 10. Der 10. da reicht es, also in Anführungszeichen reicht es, ist natürlich auch nicht so einfach, wenn du den Man magst. Wenn du einfach weißt, okay, da ist jetzt jemand bei ihm, damit er den Abschluss nicht macht. Aber er wird sich nicht zwischen die Ketten fallen lassen, der wird... Und das ist halt dann vielleicht auch ein Unterschied.
Deswegen wurde er ja dann ausgewechselt durch Alvarez, der eben im Kombinationsspiel wesentlich besser ist. Aber hinten raus hat ja Haaland eine Meterschießen gefehlt, der ein sehr sicherer Schütze ist und du hast zwei verballert. Also wie man es dreht und wendet, unglücklich.
Und Alvarez hatte 10 Pässe. Also kam natürlich jetzt auch später, in der 91. hat er noch eine halbe Stunde gespielt. Aber das ist einfach so spielt halt City aktuell. Die Gefahr kommt halt aus dem Rückraum, aus dem Halbraum und dann in den Strafraum hinein. Aber die Gefahr ist nicht quasi, schau dir an wie Harry, genau dasselbe Ding. Harry Kane hat ja auch fünf Ballkontakte, fünf Pässe gehabt, neun Ballkontakte in der ersten Hälfte.
Ganz andere Art der Einbindung bei Bayern.
Und das in der Premier League auch ausgerechnet. Also der ist immer noch, hat eine gute Energie, hat eine gute Körperlichkeit und auch Instinkte und das absolute Zutrauen in sich selbst. Deswegen passiert immer was. Aber das ist schon ausgerechnet. Also das, was der City in der vergangenen Saison das Mühe, Überraschung gegeben hat für alle anderen Gegner. Früher konntest du vorhersehen, dass sie unvorhersehbar sind. Und in der letzten Saison war es ja so, dass teilweise ein langer Ball auf Haarland und oftmals auch von der linken Seite aus, weil Grealish halt zwei Leute wie so angesogen hat. Und dann gab es halt schnell den Wechsel, sei es jetzt kurz, und dann auf Haarland in die Tiefe oder sogar mal einen diagonalen Ball auf ihn selbst. Und dann ist halt nur so was wie Chaos passiert, weil es plötzlich 1 gegen 1 oder 1 gegen 2 gewesen ist. Und das haben alle gecheckt, auch in der Premier League. Das haben alle gecheckt, dass das eigentlich die einzige Möglichkeit ist, wie sie ihn einbinden. Weil er eben niemals kurz kommt, weil er niemals auf 10 fällt oder gar tiefer. Und deswegen ist er ja vergleichsweise leicht zu verteidigen, es sei denn, du kriegst ihn wieder ins 1 gegen 1 oder ins Laufduell. Dann gibt es immer noch die Abende wie gegen Luthen im Fake-Up, wo er halt 5 macht.
Uli, du hast vorhin gesagt, Truchl hat Arsenal gegen Aston Villa angeschaut, hat sich dann den Gameplan abgeguckt, hat den umgesetzt. Ich sag, Ancelotti hat sich City gegen Arsenal angeschaut, hat den Gameplan von Ateta angesehen, hinten alles dichtmachen. Ob wir über die eigene Hälfte rauskommen oder nicht, ist uns nicht so wichtig. Und den hat er dann umgesetzt und so ist er weitergekommen. Also es war ja wirklich Arsenal gegen City in 2.0, nur halt mit einer anderen Trikotfarbe. Aber was Arsenal damals so grandios gemacht hat, hat Real Madrid jetzt wiederholt.
Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, ob es strukturell genauso war. Dazu habe ich es nur mit einem halben Auge gestern verfolgt, weil ich halt das halbe Mal auch bei Arsenal hatte und eigentlich eher sogar mehr, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, aber die grundsätzliche Herangehensweise, das auszuhalten, das ist gut möglich.
ganz kurz noch rein, du musst dann halt eben schauen, dass du Haaland die Tiefe nicht gibst. Und das haben sie ja brillant umgesetzt. Ja, aber das klingt dann einfach zu sagen, ja gut, die standen halt hinten drin, aber das hatte ja auch eine übergeordnete Idee. Weil wenn eben Haaland die Tiefe nicht kriegt und diese Läufe nicht möglich sind, dann musst du halt noch konzentriert in der Box verteidigen und das können sie. Deswegen glaube ich, wie gerade Julio hat vor dem Hinspiel gesagt, Real ist die Königin dieses Wettbewerbs und da ist halt was dran. Sie können dann auch auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise das Ganze zu Ende bringen. Ich bleibe trotzdem dabei, das war keine Taktik von Angelotti, sondern er tanzt halt einfach so viel mit seinen Spielern. Da könnte er mir erzählen, was er wollte, das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das hier irgendwie Angelotti-Taktik und so weiter gibt es ja nicht. Also damals, als er bei Bayern war, konnte der gar nichts. Genau, Friendship und bei Bayern hatte er keine Friendship, deswegen musste er weg. Gott sei Dank sind sie den los, ich freue mich auf Julian Nagelsmann.
Die Doppel war es auch nur das Abendessen in Dortmund.
Ja, eben, so ist es einfach.
So, kein Friendship, keine Party.
Kein Friendship, keine Party, langsam keine Zeit mehr.
Ist das der Folgentitel?
Ja, mal gucken, oder Pau Patrol, oder muss ich mal gucken, was ich da nehme?
Ja, Pau Patrol muss schon gewinnen, also bei aller Liebe.
Okay, ich sehe schon. So, jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich ein bisschen anziehen, langsam mit dem Tempo. Das tut mir jetzt ein bisschen leid, dass jetzt die verbleibenden Themen ein bisschen kürzer werden. Ich glaube, wir sprechen nochmal über die Serie A, wenn ich nicht komplett den Track verloren habe. Ja, gehen wir noch kurz. Es ist eigentlich auch nicht Serie A, sondern es ist Atalanta und hat dann ja auch wieder was mit Europa zu tun, weil wir nochmal über dieses 3-0 an der Anfield oder darüber auch ganz kurz, ich werde mich kurz halten, das Atalanta-Konstrukt vielleicht auch nochmal beleuchten. Also ja, 3-0 an der Anfield Road. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Mannschaften das in einem Co-Spiel gewinnen oder gewonnen haben. War ja auch schon der zweite Sieg an der Anfield Road, war so emotional, besonders, weil sie ja damals zu Corona-Zeiten schon zu Gast waren, damals noch ohne Zuschauer in der Champions League. Und deswegen hat Gasperini und für den ganzen Verein war das jetzt halt sozusagen dieses erste echte Anfield-Spiel quasi. Und das dann jetzt mit so einem Statement zu beenden, ja, Klammer auf, am heutigen Donnerstag muss das Rückspiel. Atalanta ist noch nicht weiter. Liverpool hat ja auch schon 5-0 mal im Bergoma gewonnen. Also die wissen schon, dass das das erste Halbzeit war. Aber dieses Spiel wird bleiben. Gasperini hat es auch gesagt, einfach die Art und Weise. Und auch vorhin fiel ja der Begriff, wie schön diese Vereine, die die ganze Stadt hinter sich vereinen. Wir haben das Beispiel bei Bilbao und das Beispiel Bergoma ist da halt auch ganz klar zu nennen. Das war schon vor einigen Jahren so, dass das sehr eng Bergoma und Atalanta wahnsinnig eng verknüpft wurden. Und durch die tragische Corona-Situation, die hier in Bergoma in Europa ihren Anfang nahm, ist das noch mal enger zusammengerückt. Und die Bilder hat man ja auch gesehen, wie Skamaka und Co. immer vor der Atalanta-Kurve oder direkt im Block drinnen waren. Also da ist schon, wenn Atalanta europäisch unterwegs ist, dann ist wirklich auch viel mehr als nur ein Fußballverein unterwegs. Und dementsprechend wollte ich das nur noch mal ganz kurz mitbringen. Auch dahingehend, dass Atalanta jetzt, was sagen wir jetzt, mit der April noch in allen drei Wettbewerben oder in all drei ihren Zielen ist. Also sie sind im Pokal noch im Halbfinale und in der Liga sind sie noch im Rennen um die Champions League-Quali, was sozusagen ihre Meisterschaft ist. Und dementsprechend hat Gasperini wieder mal, ich glaube sein neuntes Jahr jetzt, wieder mal eine besondere Geschichte geschrieben. Und den einen letzten Punkt möchte ich noch bringen. Ich glaube, Ulli, war es bei uns sogar, als wir vor kurzem mal Napoliger Atalanta hatten, glaube ich, da habe ich ihn mal kurz angerissen. Ich finde, das Besondere an Gasperini ist, dass mittlerweile eine ganze Trainerschule in Italien ihm so ein bisschen nacheifert. Also es gibt ja diese ganzen Palladinos, Tudors, Juric bei Torino, selbst Yago Mota, der kleinen anderen Fußballspieler, das war sein Spieler. Also sind alle von Gasperini inspiriert. Und das Besondere ist daran, dass er sich mittlerweile dadurch auch seine zukünftigen Spieler bei anderen Vereinen selbst heranzüchten lässt. Das beste Beispiel ist Isaac Hearn, ein schwedischer Innenverteidiger, den haben sie im Winter von Hellas Verona geholt. Und Hellas Verona spielt seit Jahren diesen Stil, erst unter Juric, seinem ehemaligen Kapitän, dann langen Co-Trainer, heute bei Torino, der so Atalanta 2.0 spielen lässt. Und später Tudor, der auch dieselben Prinzipien hat. Und im Prinzip hat sich Gasperini jetzt einen Innenverteidiger geholt, den er im Winter eins zu eins schon quasi in seinen Konstrukt reinsetzen konnte, weil er genau weiß, was da Gasperini Fußball ausmacht, ohne dass er überhaupt mit Gasperini einen Tag lang gearbeitet hat. Und Jen war jetzt zum Beispiel auch an der Anfield, wo der zentrale Mann in dieser Dreierkette zu Null gespielt hat gegen Liverpool, hat das davor auch gegen Napoli gemacht, hat Osemen aus dem Spiel genommen. Also das nur so als kleines Beispiel, dass sozusagen Gasperini seine eigene Kreatur geschaffen hat, die ihn jetzt auch abseits quasi von seinem eigenen Bestreben oder seinem eigenen Handeln und bei Atalanta ihre Früchte trägt und dadurch ihm auch Spieler zubringt, die unter seinen Zutun vielleicht gar nicht erst in die Richtung gegangen wären, weil eben dieses Mann orientierte 1 gegen 1 verteidigen, mutig nach vorne verteidigen, auch immer ein bisschen auf der Grenze, aber halt eben dieses risikobehaftete Antizipieren agieren. Und ja, da hat er sich sozusagen was zurecht gelegt, von dem er jetzt auch noch profitiert, auch wenn die Spieler erst mal woanders ausgebildet werden. Auch da werde ich eine Ligatur verlinken. Ich glaube, sie hieß sogar, sagt niemals Gasperini. Das waren die alten Ligaturzeiten, wo ich mich noch voll ausge… Da haben wir über diesen Gasperini-3-Antrainer auch schon… Ja, genau. Und jetzt ernt er die Früchte sozusagen auch woanders. Das ist doch stark. So, und jetzt haben wir nochmal Premier League, Uli.
Jetzt muss ich schnell überlegen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich gerne über Nottingham Forest sprechen wollen. Also gerne, das ist jetzt sehr übertrieben in dem Kontext. Aber nach all dem, was wir jetzt schon so die letzten Male gemacht haben, sind die, glaube ich, eine Weile nicht mehr vorgekommen. Und ein bisschen was hat sich getan bei denen. Und sei es nur der Punktabzug in der Länderspielpause in der letzten Mitte März. Von vier Punkten, die wir, glaube ich, auch noch nicht besprochen haben.
Doch, das haben wir schon kurz angesprochen in der letzten Sendung. Genau, das war bei den Awards mit dabei.
Ah ja, okay, möglicherweise. Also bis heute – lassen wir das Thema vielleicht weg – bis heute wahnsinnig undurchsichtig, wem, warum, was abgezogen wird. Eigentlich müsste nach meinem Dafürhalt Nottingham sogar mehr abgezogen worden sein als Everton. Aber die haben da wiederum aus Goodwill quasi plus vier wiederbekommen, so wie man liest. Aber gut, anyway. In jedem Fall seitdem die Punkte abgezogen worden sind, hat das Nottingham sehr gut gemacht. Also es ist so was wie ein Effekt eingetreten. Einmal haben sie verloren gegen Tottenham, da ist ihnen das in der zweiten Hälfte entglitten. Ansonsten viermal nicht verloren und nochmal deutlich gerade gezogen, was sowieso schon zu erkennen war unter Nuno Spirito Santo, nämlich, dass sie es etwas mehr konterzentriert spielen wollen. Also starker Fokus auf Umschalten, starker Fokus auf den Gegner kontern ab der zweiten Hälfte, was Nuno Spirito Santo ja immer schon gerne gemacht hat, dass er sich einstellt auf den Gegner und dann im zweiten Durchgang ein, zwei Änderungen vornimmt, sei es jetzt personell oder vor allen Dingen in der Herangehensweise, um dann einfach gut zu punkten gewissermaßen. Und dann ist jemand wie Chris Wood in außerordentlich guter Form, der hat dann gegen Tottenham erstmals minimal zu prassen begonnen mit seinen Möglichkeiten. An sich war das aber eine Effizienz von rund 47 Prozent die ganze Zeit über. Also wahnsinnig gefährlich der Typ mal wieder. Also das ist die x-te Auferstehung von dem und das ist x-te Mal, dass der in genau so einem System dann funktioniert. Und das, obwohl Taibo Avonie zum Beispiel eben nicht mit dabei sein kann verletzungsbedingt, gibt's White, wäre sogar ein Ausnahmeherausforderer für Player of the Season, weil er wirklich unglaublich wichtig und gut spielt und vieles auf sich zieht, wahnsinnig dynamisch sein kann. Karl-Heinz Notoi sieht gut aus auf eine Weise inzwischen, die ich nicht mehr dachte bei ihm zu sehen, weil bei mir die Ernsthaftigkeit gefällt. Und der war ja auch zu Leverkusener Zeiten einfach kaputt körperlich. Der sieht auch gut aus, spielt jetzt endlich auf dem linken Flügel, auch das passt ganz gut. Die haben den Verteidiger drin in Murillo, den jagen sie ja in Spanien. Also sowohl Barca als auch Real Madrid sollen großes Interesse haben. Der würde für meine Verhalten sogar eher zu Atletico passen. Der macht Spaß, der spielt so ganz fiese Killer-Diagonalbälle. Und zwar kostet es, was ich es wolle. Der schlägt die einfach lang und weit. Und der macht Spaß, hat so einen besonderen Flair an sich. Danilo im Mittelfeld gefällt mir wieder gut. Der war letztes Jahr in der Rückrunde schon mal sehr, sehr stark. Er hatte dann einen völligen Durchhänger. Hat überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und gefällt mir gerade wieder einigermaßen gut. Seit 2, 3 Wochen jetzt auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob es zusammenhängt. Würde mich aber wundern, wenn nicht. Das ist natürlich motivatorisch mit, wahrscheinlich das Leichteste, was man machen kann. Und das sagt man ja nun als Spirito Santo sowieso nach, dass das seine große Fähigkeit ist, Leute gehend zu machen. Und ich würde schon auch tippen, dass es daran hängt, dass der gesagt hat, passt auf, also eigentlich sind wir weg, aber da liegt die Chance drin und jetzt zeigen wir es denen einmal mehr.
Sehr interessant. Ich bin gespannt, wie das bei Nottingham weitergeht überhaupt. Der Abstiegskampf in allen Ligen ist gerade interessant. Also da hätte man vorhin bei UDN nicht mehr die Zeit, diese Ausfahrt auch noch zu nehmen. Aber auch sehr interessant, hier in der Premier League definitiv auch. Also ich habe das Gefühl, da werden wir noch öfter drüber sprechen. Jetzt schauen wir noch kurz auf unsere Awards. Und wir feiern die jetzt nacheinander. Folgen wir die je Liga raus. Jetzt drehe ich nicht mehr die vielen Extraschleifen noch. David, du darfst gerne beginnen. MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Was gibt es da noch zu sagen?
Ja, also ich habe als Man of the Match einen Menschen mitbekommen, von dem ich ehrlich gesagt zugeben muss, ich weiß noch nicht mal genau, wie man ihn offiziell ausspricht, weil er ist Georgier. Ich kann keinen Georgisch. Ich spreche ihn jetzt aus, wie die Phrasose ihn ausspricht. Ich spreche nämlich George Mikotatse. Also er schreibt sich Georges Mikotatse auf Deutsch. Ich habe gedacht, ich weiß es nicht. 23 aus Georgien ist auch Teil des Nationalteams, dass er jetzt bei der EURO dabei ist. Wir sind ja im Bildungspodcast hier. Neben den zwei georgischen Superstars aus Neapel und Valencia, kennt ihr jetzt auch noch einen dritten, ist bei Metz aktuell wichtigster Spieler des Teams, hat sieben Tore in sieben Spielen geschossen, unter anderem die zwei gegen Lanz am Wochenende. Deshalb habe ich ihn jetzt hier gekürt. Hat Lanz von seinen Europa-Ammissionen abgehalten. Metz dafür ist im Abstiegskampf, struggled da gerade, schöpft da jetzt wieder Hoffnung, kam einen harten Fight mit Le Havre und Lorient. Und Nikotaze hat den Spitzennamen Roi Georges, also König Georges oder König Georg, was insofern ein bisschen bezahlt ist. König Georges. Weil es gab nie einen König Georg in Frankreich. Es gab drei, die sich König von Frankreich genannt haben, aber das waren die drei Georgs von Großbritannien im 17. und 18. Jahrhundert. Alle aus dem Haus Hannover, die haben sich alle noch König von Frankreich genannt, weil sie ja da im 100-jährigen Krieg hatten, sie ja Besitztümer, und dann hat England gesagt, ja, wir sind aber immer noch König von Frankreich. Bis dann besagter George III hat dann gesagt, nee, den Titel brauchen wir nicht mehr, den legen wir jetzt ab, nachdem sie ja schon sehr, sehr lange auch da nichts mehr hatten. Vorbild für die Franzosen kann der aber auch nicht sein, weil der hat Napoleon besiegt und hat den Kolonien abgenommen. Das geht ja überhaupt nicht. Insofern ein großes Rätsel, warum Franzosen jemanden Roa Georges nennt, ich weiß es nicht. Aber dieser Georg jedenfalls ganz wichtig. Er war eigentlich an Ajax schon verkauft, kam im Winter als Leitspieler zurück und ist jetzt die Hoffnung für Metz.
Und ich finde das so schön, dass er für Georg Guien spielt.
Neben meinen Witzen. Mein Anzang Hero. Wo habe ich den jetzt?
Wir gehen nach Brest.
Ich weiß, genau. Zu Marco Pizot. 33 Jahre, kommt aus Holland. Und er ist eigentlich – streng genommen ist er gar nicht unbedingt so anzang. Er ist tatsächlich einer der besten Torhüter der Liga. Das ist ein Grund, warum Brest gerade da oben steht, wo sie stehen. Ich habe ihn aber als Anzang genommen, wegen seiner persönlichen Geschichte. Er war vorher bei Alkmaar, hat seinem Agenten gesagt, er will mal im Ausland spielen unbedingt. Ich hätte gerne einen Club mit Sonne und Strand, hat er gesagt. Und dann kam Brest. Na gut, Sonne ist hier nicht immer, Strand haben wir. Und der stammt aus einer Familie, die einen Verein für Flüchtlingshilfe gegründet hat. Das hat er auch selbst gemacht. Er hat Flüchtlingen geholfen, unter anderem. Jetzt kommt meine Anzang-Story, einem Flüchtling aus Eritrea. Da hat er bei Papieren geholfen usw. Und er hat dem Mann gar nicht erzählt, dass er Torwart ist, also damals noch bei Alkmaar. Er hat ihm aber zwei Tickets geschenkt, Amsterdam gegen Alkmaar. Da war er anscheinend total happy und war dann beim nächsten Spiel dabei. Das Problem war, dieser Mann war ganz großer Ajax-Fan. Und beim nächsten Treffen hat er dann gesagt, wir haben verloren, weil der Torwart von Alkmaar war so gut. Und jetzt bin ich total traurig. Und er hat es also offenbar nicht aufgelöst, dass er dieser Torwart ist. Fand ich eine ganz, ganz wunderschöne Anekdote, scheint aber auch wirklich sehr beliebt zu sein. Und damit kommen wir zum Moment des Spieltags. Da spielt eben jeder Torwart auch nochmal eine Rolle. Im Moment des Spieltags war das gesamte Spiel Lyon gegen Brest. Das ist 4 zu 3 für Lyon ausgegangen. Das fing sehr harmlos an. Da ist Tolisso für Lyon Führung gegangen, stand so halbzeit 1 zu 0 und dann bricht die Hölle los, weil Brest plötzlich 3 zu 1 für drei Tore von acht Minuten. Die haben auch nochmal gezeigt, warum sie wirklich nach wie vor da oben stehen an zweiter Stelle. Pressing, Stellungsspiegel, Konta und so. Alles ganz toll gemacht. Und dann plötzlich dreht Lyon auf und dann schießen die zwei Tore in zehn Minuten. Und das ist immer noch nicht der Höhepunkt, weil in der sechsnachsten Minute geraten dann Les Melous von Brest und Thalja Fico von Lyon aneinander. Nach einem Faul bleibt dann Les Melous liegen und Thalja Fico wittert halt Zeitspiegel, in der sechsnachsten Minute und hebt ihn so richtig im Ringerstil am angewinkelten Arm, fast komplett in die Höhe. Dann geraten beide im Handgewinkel aneinander und der Schiedsrichter gibt beiden eine rote Karte, schickt sie beide vom Feld. Total vogelwilde Schlussphase. Und dann müsste besagter Torwart Bissot eigentlich vom Platz fliegen in der 97. Der geht mit den Knien voran in den Gegner rein. Es gibt eine lange VR-Szene. Und es gibt offiziell einen Elfmeter. Der ist dann in der 106. Minute. Also 90 plus 16 wird er ausgeführt. Und dann siegt Lyon in der 90 plus 16. Minute mit 4 zu 3.
Moment, aber der Elfmeter und das Vr war in der 96. Und die Ausführung war dann erst in der…
In der 97. Genau, ja, ja.
Das heißt, die haben zehn Minuten dann gebraucht.
Ja, mit VR und allem.
Kann ich nochmal den Kölner Keller sehen? Das ist doch schön, wenn so Sachen relativiert werden. Also dieses Spiel, das hat sich definitiv gelohnt.
Genau. Und um das einzuordnen, also Brest auf Europacourse trotzdem wäre die erste Teilnahme seit 74 Jahren. Und ist auch wirklich eine tolle Mannschaft. Also so vom Spektakel her haben Vortag 4 zu 3 gegen Metz gewonnen. Und Lyon hat aber seine Europateilnehmer auch an selbst in der Hand. Die sind ja im Finale gegen PSG im Pokal. Das heißt, entweder schaffen – also nochmal, Lyon, ja? Das ist die, wo ich am Anfang der Saison gesagt habe, die sind abgestiegen. Die sind sicher abgestiegen, hatte ich erzählt. Und das sah auch danach aus, die könnten es mittlerweile schaffen, auf die Europapolizei selbst zu kommen. Und selbst wenn sie nur einen Platz dahinter kommen, können sie sagen, ja gut, wenn wir gewinnen, den Pokal, dann sind wir drin. Und wenn PSG gewinnt, sind wir auch drin, weil dann – Sehr gut.
Sehr gut. Damit sind wir mit der Ligue 1 durch. Jetzt frühstücken wir La Liga ab. Alex, MVP, Anzung, Hero und Moment bitte.
Wir bleiben Georgien. Wir haben uns nicht abgesprochen, David und ich. Aber ich habe auch einen Georgier dabei. Und zwar Georgi Mamadasvili. Also auch da kannst du jetzt einen kleinen Namenswitz machen, Max, wenn du willst. Das ist der Torwart von Valencia, der eine starke Serie vorzuweisen hat, die vielleicht so ein bisschen untergeht, also auch in Spanien untergeht. Er hat seit sieben Spielen kein Gegentor mehr kassiert mit Land und Verein. Also mit Valencia sind es fünf Spiele am Stück. Davor, glaube ich, hat er zwei kassiert und davor auch zweimal zu Null. Also er hält einfach die Kiste sauber. Und mit Georgien, die haben ja die Playoffs gewonnen, sind bei der Euro dabei. Beide Spiele auch zu Null gespielt. Also sieben Spiele in Folge, kein Gegentor, wirklich eine beachtliche Leistung. Ich weiß jetzt ad hoc nicht, was da irgendein Rekord sein könnte, aber es ist eine durchaus beachtliche Serie. Er hat auch drei von fünf Elfmetern in der Saison gehalten, hat insgesamt zwölf Mal für Valencia schon zu Null gehalten. Also das ist ein richtig, richtig guter Mann im Tor von Valencia. Und Valencia auch deswegen beachtenswert. Die sind so ein bisschen Augsburg-mäßig, schnuppern die an Europa und das konnte man auch nicht so richtig erwarten. Chaos Club letztes Jahr knapp dem Abstieg entronnen und ich hätte auch gedacht, die werden wieder richtig Probleme haben. Aber könnten eben nächstes Jahr Europäspiel, ich glaube siebte oder achte sind sehr aktuell. Und da schiebt sich ja dann wahrscheinlich auch ein Platz nach unten durch. Dann könnten sie in der Conference League dabei sein. Bilbao hat ja die Koppa gewonnen. Und deswegen ja, hat Valencia eine sehr, sehr gute Saison. Und ein Grund ist eben der Torhüter, wo man mal das Spiel der Georgia, der da eine sehr, sehr starke Leistung zeigt.
Sehr, sehr schön. Dein geteilter Anzang Hero und MVP.
Nee, das ist Anzang Hero, ich hab's dann doch nochmal. Also Anzang, weil man liest nicht so viel davon. Ich mach's minimal kurz, MVP muss Ernesto Valverde sein, der Copa-Champion-Coach vom Athletikklub aus Bilbao, der jetzt mit denen die Copa gewonnen hat. Bei Barca ja auch damals zweimal Meister geworden, Pokal gewonnen, in Pireos glaube ich auch Meister gewonnen, Pokal gewonnen. Also wirklich ein ganz, ganz großer Erfolgscoach. Ich musste da ein bisschen dran denken. Sehr viele große Vereine suchen ja einen Trainer im Sommer. Warum wird Valverde eigentlich nicht genannt? Ähnlich wie in Italien, wo du dir denkst, da ist jemand bei Atalanta, der auch keinen schlechten Job macht. Aber irgendwie so richtig kommt der Name nicht vor in Europa, wenn es darum geht, die Top-Vereine zu besetzen. Das ist bei Ernesto Valverde ähnlich. Und deswegen wollte ich ihn hier als MVP dann doch nennen, wenn er mit seinem Verein da diesen Triumph nach 40 Jahren schafft. Dann muss er MVP sein.
Finde ich sehr gut. Und dann hast du uns aber auch noch einen Moment mitgebracht.
Ja, sportlich nicht so relevant. Ossasuna ist im Mittelfeld, kann nicht absteigen, kann nicht nach oben und ob sie jetzt gewinnen oder verlieren. Valencia war beteiligt, das war die 97. Minute. Ossasuna gegen Valencia. Ossasuna hat einen Elfmeter bekommen. Ante Budimir, der Ex-St. Pauli-Spieler, tritt an, hat drei Gedanken gleichzeitig. Alle drei davon sind nicht so prickelnd, aber die Mischung wird dann zum Chaos. Und dann stolpert er diesen Elfmeter dem Torhüter in die Arme. Also er wusste wirklich nicht, was er machen soll. Macht er diesen Stutter-Stab-Elfmeter, diesen Ausguck-Elfmeter von Jorginho und Lewandowski und wie sie alle heißen, oder schießt er normal oder reagiert er auf den Torwart und dann stolpert er beim Schießen. Und ja, stolpert den Ball kläglich in der 97. Minute dem Torwart in die Arme. Es wäre sonst das 1-1 gewesen. Also so haben sie 0-1 verloren. Der Sohn hat es, glaube ich, auf Twitter X geteilt. Die Szene wirklich slapstick pur und mit der peinlichsten Elfer Spielschuss wahrscheinlich aller Zeiten. Mal einen Superlativ raushauen hier.
Ja, hatten wir heute noch nicht so viel. Bester Verteidiger, den ich jemals gesehen habe und so weiter. Aber es ist ja schön, dass nicht nur Manchester City in die Tormitte schießt und dann wird einfach pariert. Aber da wollen wir jetzt nicht wieder zurückgehen. Wir holen uns noch schnell von Christian MVP Ansang Hero und Moment. Ja, MVP hätte man Skamaka nehmen können, der an der Anfield-Vorhau zweimal getroffen hat, das dritte mit eingeleitet hat und jetzt in der Liga gleich ein Tor und Assist nachgelegt hat. Aber Atalanta hatten wir ja schon gerade eben. Deswegen bleibe ich in der Schiene, auf der auch gerade Alex war, erfahrene Trainer, Sir Claudio Ranieri. Mittlerweile ja in Caliari unterwegs. Und Caliari positioniert sich gerade in den letzten Wochen sehr, sehr gut im Abstiegskampf. Das ist angesprochen wahnsinnig eng. Sechs oder sieben Mannschaften, die da innerhalb weniger Punkte sind. Und Caliari hat am Wochenende 2-2 in San Siro gespielt bei Inter, zweimal nach Rückstand zurückgekommen, hat in der 95. Riesenchance aufs 3-2, hat in der Woche davor, kurz vor dem Liverpool-Spiel, Atalanta geschlagen, hat gegen Napoli auch gepunktet vor kurzem. Und das Besondere daran ist, wegen der MVP, in den letzten acht Spielen nur einmal verloren und vor diesen acht Spielen hat Ranieri seinen Rücktritt angeboten, weil er gemeint hat, die Mannschaft braucht so ein Signal. Und die Mannschaft hat ihn dann zu bewegen, zu bleiben, der Verein auch. Und der auffahrene Fuchs hat anscheinend die richtigen Knöpfe gedrückt und seitdem eben, wie gesagt, acht Spiele, nur eine Liga, gepunktet gegen die Top-Klubs. Am Wochenende kommt Juve, wäre ich nicht überrascht, wenn sie gegen Juve auch was mitnehmen. Dementsprechend, ja, sie sind weiter mitten drin im Abstiegsring, aber sie haben so ein kleines Polster und sind auf einem sehr guten Weg. Deswegen Ranieri mit all seiner Erfahrung der MVP. Stark! Und wer ist denn Anzang Hero? Anzang Hero, nehmen wir mal ein bisschen was anderes. Anzang Hero ist der Vertrag von Luis Alberto von Lazio. Der wurde vergangenen Herbst verlängert. Luis Alberto ist einer der wichtigsten Spieler seit Jahren bei Lazio. Gerade als im letzten Sommer Yamilinkovic Savic verkauft wurde, er und die Mobile die zwei großen Identifikationsfiguren. Luis Alberto hat seinen Vertrag im Herbst verlängert bis 2027. Und jetzt, am vergangenen Spieltag, stellt er sich direkt nach dem Spiel vor die Dason-Kameras und sagt übrigens, das wird mein letztes Jahr in Rom. Ich werde nächstes Jahr nicht mehr hier sein. Es ist Zeit, dass das Geld, er möchte keinen Cent vom Verein. Es ist Zeit, hat er gemeint, dass das Geld, das ihm per Vertrag zusteht, anderen zugutekommt. Also wirklich einen ganz klaren Cut gezogen, noch mal nachdem er vor ein paar Monaten den Vertrag bis 2027 verlängert hat. Ja, und die Reaktion von Lazio hat nicht lange auf sich warten lassen, von Herrn Lotito, dem Präsidenten, der gemeint hat, erstmal Kollege, bring uns einen Verein, der uns eine Ablöse zahlt. Ablöse freigehen kannst du dir abschminken. Wir sind ein börsennotierter Verein. Du erzählst hier öffentlich Geschichten, die ja logischerweise auch unserer Wirtschaftlichkeit sehr in die Quere kommen. Deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie die ganze Nummer ausgeht. Luis Alberto scheint fest entschlossen zu sein. Die letzten Jahre gab es auch immer wieder schon mal Gerüchte, dass er zurück nach Spanien möchte. Aber ich bin gespannt, wie beide Seiten das jetzt irgendwie so lösen, dass das sozusagen passt. Ich kann die Lazio-Seite auch komplett verstehen. Luis Alberto ist ein Spieler mit einer gewissen Klasse, auch wenn er mittlerweile in die Jahre gekommen ist. Also da ist es logischerweise auch für Lazio mehr als nachvollziehbar, dass da dann auch eine gewisse Ablöse ist, um ihn noch heranzubringen, zu Karren sei. Also ganz kurioses Zähne. Mal schauen, wie uns Steven Sommer noch beschäftigt. Ich habe nur eine Nachfrage dazu, die ist aber auch extrem wichtig. Sagt man auch im italienischen XY hat Vertrag? XY hat Vertrag? Nein, sagt man nicht. Nein, leider nicht.
Ach, ich liebe Italienisch.
Leider nicht. Ich habe selbst auch schon verwendet diese deutsche Formulierung. Gut, was ist dein Moment des Spieltags? Der Moment liegt in der Zukunft, aber noch sehr nah an, nämlich am kommenden Montagabend findet in San Siro das Derby Milan gegen Inter statt. Das ist ja immer eine große Sache. Dieses Jahr kann es eine noch größere Sache sein, denn Inter kann Meister werden. Das im Auswärtsderby, also Milan hat Heimrecht, dass Inter Meister werden wird, steht außer Frage. Aber jetzt haben sie auch noch diese Möglichkeit, im Derby bei Milan auswärts das Ganze einzutüten. Logischerweise ist da der volle Fokus drauf. Inter seit der Champions-League-Ausgang in der Liga, jetzt ein, zweimal auch so ein bisschen, sage ich mal, lala. Das war logisch ein Riesenrückschlag für sie. Es war klar, dass die Meisterschaft nur noch mitzunehmen ist. Ich glaube, der Fokus für Montag wird sehr, sehr groß sein. Inter legt alles darauf hin, im Derby. Das gab es erst einmal in der Geschichte des Milanern Derbys, dass eine Mannschaft im Derby Meister geworden ist. Dementsprechend bei Milan kommt ihr noch dazu. Die spielen heute Abend das wichtige Europa League-Rückspiel noch in Rom. Die haben nicht nur körperliche, sondern auch mentale Belastung. Inter ist die ganze Woche schon im Vorbereitungsmodus. Im Hintergrund läuft logisch auch schon die großen Vorbereitungen zu den ganzen Scudetto-Feierlichkeiten, die so oder so kommen werden. Aber Inter wird alles daran setzen, das Ganze im Derby einzutüten. Sie müssen dazu gewinnen. Mit einem Sieg wären sie es mathematisch, ansonsten wären sie es kurz darauf. Montag Abend, Montag deshalb, weil Milan am Donnerstag noch spielt. Und deshalb das Spiel nach hinten geschoben wurde. 20.45 Uhr, ich nehme an, wird man sehen können auf der Zone? Definitiv, genau. Na, da freuen wir uns doch drauf. Und dann freuen wir uns jetzt noch auf MBP Anzang Hero und Moment des Spieltags von Uli.
Ich fange mal mit dem MBP an und nehme Alexander Isak, weil ich fürchte, dass er sich sonst wieder verletzt und ich ihn nie wieder nennen kann. Der ist gerade gesund und da sieht man mal, was in dem Körper steckt, was mit dem Typen grundsätzlich los sein könnte. Er hat jetzt das sechste Heimspiel in Folge getroffen, hat über 20 Tore schon in allen Wettbewerben erzielt. Es ist im Moment einer der Gründe, dass es für Newcastle doch nochmal so aussieht, als könnten sie Richtung Europa gehen, wahrscheinlich eher Europa League als irgendwas anderes. Champions League halte ich jetzt nicht mehr für realistisch, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich in dieser Saison das höchste aller Gefühle, wenn sie das hinbekommen würden und direkt einen starken Anteil dran. Es ist so etwas wie der perfekte Stürmer für das System von Newcastle, wird aber auch für ganz, ganz viele andere Vereine interessant werden, wenn der weiter so performt. Weil es das in seiner Karriere eben einfach noch nie gegeben hat und weil er aber grundsätzlich aus so oft schwierigen Situationen dann doch wieder so stark zurückgekommen ist, sei der jetzt hier stellvertretend mal auch für Newcastle genannt. Da musste ich ein bisschen überlegen, wie wenig ich mich jetzt letztlich entscheide. Ich hatte kurz mal gedacht David Moyes, weil über den singt wahrscheinlich echt niemand jemals Lieder. Zu Recht auch irgendwie, wenn man die Art und Weise des Fußballs sieht. Aber es funktioniert einigermaßen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird dann doch wieder viel gesungen am Donnerstagabend. Deswegen lasse ich das mal bleiben und gehe zu Timo Werner.
Über den gibt es Lieder, aber keine Positiven.
Well played. Einfach auch da aus dem Grund, seitdem der bei Tottenham ist, spielt er. Mal stamm, mal nicht. In den letzten Wochen ist er sogar Stammspieler geworden. Hat sich ziemlich klar vor Kolusevski festgesetzt im Moment auf der linken Seite. Er hat eigentlich eine ganz gute Chemie, vor allen Dingen mit Brandon Johnson. Wenn man sich die Zahlen so anguckt, dann ist er alle 100 Minuten im Schnitt an dem Tor beteiligt, wie auch immer, geartet. Das ist wie immer auch bei Timo Werner. Da sind ein paar Dinge dabei, die sind gut. Ein paar, die sind einfach bei ihm nicht gut, die werden auch nicht mehr gut, und die sind auch im Spiel dabei. Als Beispiel gegen Nottingham waren es fünf Flanken, zwar in der Partie, aber zeitgleich 14 Ballverluste. Trotzdem sorgt er mit seiner Art und Weise, wie er spielt, mit seinem Tempo auf dem Flügel dafür, weil er selber manchmal nicht genau weiß, wo es hingehen soll. Auch der Gegner das nicht ganz genau weiß. Worauf ich hinaus will und warum Anzangen, weil erstens darüber in Deutschland wenig berichtet wird und wurde, über die Dinge, die nicht zählbar sind. Und das andere ist, es gibt eine Kaufoption, die soll wohl so bei 15 Millionen Pfund liegen. Und das ist zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt für Tottenham, glaube ich, eine klare Sache, dass man den verpflichten muss. So viel wie Possecolu mit im Spiel, der kommt mit dem Tempo klar, als dann wahrscheinlich, sage ich jetzt mal, Auffüllspieler im Kader oder Joker oder eben für gewisse Situationen. Glaube ich, dass da kein Zweifel daran besteht, dass sie den verpflichten. Der ist relativ leicht. Da habe ich parallel gestreamt, habe es mir dann im Nachhinein nochmal angucken müssen. Vier Tore von Cole Palmer gegen Everton. Also das ist allein schon mal fast unmöglich, gegen Everton vier Tore zu machen, beim 6.0. Und der hätte natürlich auch das MVP herhalten können, weil ohne den wäre Chelsea anderswo. Aber hat, glaube ich, das Momentum für sich alleine aufgrund der vier Tore gepachtet, dass alle nochmal darüber gesprochen haben, da hat Goldiola vielleicht einen großen Fehler gemacht, da hat Chelsea vielleicht einen großen Stil gemacht, obwohl der viel Geld gekostet hat. Mir ist – bei Chelsea verlässt man sich etwas viel auf den, finde ich, was nicht sein Fehler ist, im Gegenteil, ist ein sehr guter Spieler. Aber sein nochmal zu nennen, das ist schon, wann immer jemand vier Tore in einem Spiel macht, das ist besonders. Und deswegen am Montagabend, das ist ja in England eine Zeit, die man sehr gerne hat, deswegen schöner Moment.
Ich muss übrigens ganz, ganz kurz noch den Bogen zum Anfang schlagen. Will Stil ist großer West Ham-Fan, das ist hinterlegt. Sollte West Ham da mit David Moisum hier unzufrieden sein, an den Instrument wagen, der würde mit Kusshand kommen.
Das glaube ich gerne. Bei West Ham, was ich höre, ist man sich immer noch unentschieden. Also Stilten ist nicht David Mois größter Fan. Aber David Moisum ist auch nicht Stilten größer Fan.
Sehr gut, hätten wir das auch noch geklärt. Ihr drei, ihr vier inzwischen. Ich danke euch ganz, ganz herzlich. Die genaue Begrüßung, die schenken wir uns. Wir müssen schnell fertig machen. Ich danke auch Steve, Jan, Benedict Geisler, Paul D. Nelson, Tony S gar kein Fußballfan und Cara. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club, da könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Und bitte tut das auch, indem ihr Folgen wie diese hier weiter empfiehlt. Die Ligatour müssen immer noch mehr Leute hören. Ich sage es euch. Liebe Hörer, trotzdem danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.